So, Jason's got to pee. I got to take a nap, will. But maybe we can get the show done and then I can pee in my seat here? How does that work? You should do that. You should get one of those. Or should get one of those microphones that like singers use. I can just take it to the bathroom right on a long cord. And then do you guys mind if I take a nap while you do that? Are you ever awake? Welcome to smartlet. So, hi Will, hi Sean.
所以，杰森得去撒尿。我得去打个盹，威尔。不过也许我们把节目录完，然后我就可以在这里的座位上撒尿？这怎么操作？你真该这么干。你应该弄一个那种东西。或者弄那种歌手用的麦克风。我可以拿着它直接连着长长的一根线去洗手间。然后大家介不介意你们录的时候我打个盹？你到底有没有清醒过？欢迎来到SmartLess。那么，嗨，威尔，嗨，肖恩。
Hi Jason. How are you? Doing a hostage video. Where are you? Yeah. I'm safe. I'm fine. I'm holding up today's newspaper. Are you in Atlanta? I am. I'm in Atlanta. Are you in the dressing room?
嗨，杰森。你好吗？像在拍人质视频。你在哪？对的。我很安全。我很好。我正举着今天的报纸呢。你在亚特兰大吗？是的。我在亚特兰大。你在化妆室吗？
I'm in an office. I'm in a production office. Oh really? So what you have is like a little break. You have a little lunch hour. They built it around our record today. That's what they do down here. Everybody's real helpful. Let's just drink him in for a second. I've been drinking for years. Even on a hostage video lighting set up.
我在办公室。我在制作办公室。哦，真的吗？所以你现在有个小小的休息时间。你有一个小小的午休。他们是根据我们今天的录制时间来安排的。他们在这里就是这么做的。每个人都特热心。让我们好好欣赏他一会儿吧。我已经喝了好多年了。即使在人质视频的灯光布景下也是。
He looks just, what's going on down there? I have free refills with looking at Will. I just fill up every time. Right? Just pour him over you. Will, are you sick? No, thank you for asking. No, no, no. It's a real sharp jawline.
他看起来真是……那里的情况怎么样？看着威尔，我有免费续杯的感觉。我每次都能充满电。对吧？简直就像把快乐倾注在你身上。威尔，你生病了吗？不，谢谢你的关心。不，不，不。这下颌线真是太硬朗了。
I know. Cut yourself. I'm here and I kind of say again, everybody's super nice. Remember last time I was here, I was dealing with a lot of issues at a certain department store with the Glory Hole. Yes. You do remember that.
我知道。都能割伤人了。我在这儿，而且我还是得说一遍，每个人都超级好。还记得我上次来这儿的时候吗，我在某个百货公司的“光洞”遇到了很多麻烦。对。你确实记得那件事。
I'll never forget. Why would I not remember a Glory Hole story? This year we're dealing with the same guy who told us about that, is telling us about this app, which is that he's on to meet people. Sure.
我永远不会忘。我怎么可能不记得一个关于“光洞”的故事呢？今年我们遇到了同一个人，就是那个跟我们讲过那件事的人，他又跟我们讲了这个约会软件，也就是他在上面结识朋友。当然。
And now it's not even like a tender thing where it's just like, face comes up and it's or grinder where it's just other guys. It's just action shots. So he showed us a photo he got from a guy and it's just his rear hand,
而且现在这甚至不像Tinder那种会弹出脸的照片，或者像Grinder那样全是其他男人的软件。这上面全都是动作特写。所以他给我们看了一张他从一个家伙那儿弄来的照片，那是他的屁股，
rear end, naked rear end and his garbage hanging and all from behind. So he's bulldogging him. And then he just said, howdy. This is an app he pays for?
屁股，光溜溜的屁股，然后垂着他的那啥，全都是从后面拍的。所以他这是在“斗牛”。然后他只说了一句：“哈喽”。这是一个他花钱买的软件？
Yes, I don't know. I couldn't believe it. Which one's for the fellas? Is that the tender or the grinder? So this is a much more this is just down to business. This is just like, here's what you're looking at. Like cut to the chase.
是的，我不知道。我简直不敢相信。哪一个才是给小伙子们用的？是Tinder还是Grinder？所以这个要直白得多，这个就是单刀直入。这就像是，这就是你要看的东西。也就是直奔主题。
It's a step above grinder. It's a different name. I don't even know what it is and it's just oh, I do it. Look, I get it. It's cut to the chase. Why the small talk? Are we going to do it or not? This is what I got going on right now.
它比Grinder高一个级别。名字都不一样。我甚至不知道它叫什么，但我懂，我懂。看，我明白了。就是直奔主题。干嘛还要闲聊？到底干不干？这就是我目前的情况。
Where are you at? This is what you're going to be dealing with. Are you in or you out because I got to move on. The girls don't get that. The girls need to be talked to and emotional and then that turns them on. But the guy on guy thing is just like, look, I know what I want.
你在哪儿？这就是你要面对的。你到底进不进，还是不玩了，因为我还得继续呢。女孩们可不懂这个。女孩们需要聊天，要有情感交流，然后这才能勾起她们的欲望。但男对男的事情就是：听着，我知道我想要什么。
I know what I'd like. Let's just do it or not do it. Right? That's the fun part. Howdy. Will, did he tell you about this or did you ask for a visual proof? No, he was excited.
我知道我喜欢什么。咱们干脆就痛快点，做还是不做。对吧？这才是好玩的部分。哈喽。威尔，他是主动跟你说这个的，还是你管他要了视觉证据？不，他可兴奋了。
This is my buddy and he's like, wait till you see what I got going on this year. You're not going to be able to believe it. And then he shows me that and I'm like, oh my God. It was so... You know?
这是我的哥们儿，他当时说，你等着看我今年有什么好玩的。你绝对不敢相信。然后他就把那个给我看，我就想，天呐。当时真是……你知道吗？
So funny though. Sean, is your life as exciting currently? Yes, I do. I think we all have something to talk about which is our docu-series on Max. Yes. Right, coming out.
不过太搞笑了。肖恩，你现在的生活也这么精彩吗？是的，确实如此。我想我们都有事情要聊，那就是我们在Max上的纪录片系列。对。没错，即将上映。
Smartlist on the Road. It's a six part documentary series on Max. What's the date? It's the 23rd. May 23rd? Yes. And it's just basically us three idiots. Yeah, we're traveling around
《人在囧途：SmartLess》（Smartlist on the Road）。这是在Max上播出的六集纪录片系列。具体日期是几号？23号。5月23号？对。这基本上就是我们三个白痴。对，我们在到处奔波，
because we took this show on the road to a bunch of different theaters around the country. And it's us traveling and living in the same hotel room and eating and flying. I mean, if you thought you were bored with us before, wait till you watch this.
因为我们把这个节目带到了全国各地的很多不同剧院进行巡演。这就是我们旅行、住在同一个酒店房间、吃东西、坐飞机。我的意思是，如果你以前觉得看我们觉得烦，那就等着看这个吧。
Yeah, this is guaranteed. When you see us flying... Some people use white noise to sleep. There is actual... I think we have some shots of you eating which I think fans will be fascinated by. Those are fun. Well, it's rare.
对，这是绝对的。当你看到我们坐飞机……有些人用白噪音来助眠。这里面实际上有……我想我们有一些你吃东西的镜头，粉丝们肯定会觉得很着迷。那些挺好玩的。嗯，这很少见。
It's like sighting Yeti. And there's a lot of talking about eating. We've got plenty of shots of you guys eating. Good Lord. And in cold, it was all cold. Jason, you ordered... Jason ended up being the default ordering
就像看见雪人一样。而且里面有很多关于吃东西的对话。我们有大量你们在吃东西的镜头。天呐。而且在寒冷的天气里，全都是冷的。杰森，你点单……杰森最后成了默认的客房送餐点单员。
room service guy. And I noticed one thing I didn't want to bring it up because often I would notice when you were placing the order, you had full bone. LAUGHTER Just ordering food. LAUGHTER
我注意到了一件事，我本来不想提的，因为我经常会注意到，当你点餐的时候，你整个人都硬了。笑声 就只是在点餐。笑声
The forbidden fruit? Yeah. It's his body responding, getting so excited about getting food inside of him. Yeah. So it is... We like the show, but we're biased.
禁果？对。这是他的身体在做出反应，一想到有食物要进到他肚子里就兴奋得不得了。对。所以……我们挺喜欢这个节目的，不过我们带了主观色彩。
I hope you do too. May 23rd on Max. I don't know. It's us. It's just this. You get to see what we talk. You get to see us instead of just hear us. We do these interviews on stage, great guests, but then it's also all the travel in between the spots.
希望你们也喜欢。5月23号在Max上线。我不知道。就是我们。也就是这样。你们能看到我们在聊什么。你们能看到真实的我们，而不仅仅是听到声音。我们在舞台上做这些采访，有很棒的嘉宾，但其中还包括所有这些演出地点之间的旅程。
Check it out. That's on Max. It's called Smartlist on the Road. Yes. Sean, speaking of doing the show and being on the road, didn't somebody recently just call you... I just texted you guys an hour ago. I was walking on Broadway
去看看吧。就在Max上。名字叫《人在囧途：SmartLess》。对。肖恩，说到做节目和巡演，最近难道不是有人刚叫你……我一个小时前刚给你们发了短信。我当时正在百老汇散步，
and some guy goes, hey, it's Jason from Smartlist. And I just smiled and I said, super guy, go, hi! And then you pushed your stomach out. Did that just tell me? I unzipped my zipper and I stuck my fat stomach out. LAUGHTER I said, oh, Zark, oh, Zark.
有个家伙走过来说，嘿，这不是SmartLess的杰森吗！我只是笑了笑，然后说，太棒了，你好！然后你把肚子挺出去了。刚才是这么跟我说的吗？我拉开拉链，把胖肚子挺了出去。笑声 我说，哦，扎克，哦，扎克。
I just asked that's all I did. Right on Broadway. LAUGHTER But isn't that funny? Watch out, Zark, girl! I just did. You know what I was doing this morning? I was talking to a New York Times journalist about you, Sean.
我刚才就是这么问的，就这么简单。就在百老汇。笑声 但这难道不好笑吗？小心点，扎克老弟！我刚才就是这么做的。你知道我今天早上在干嘛吗？我正在和一个《纽约时报》的记者谈论你，肖恩。
You've got, he's doing this, some sort of a profile on you. And so, listener, when a journalist has profile on a famous friend, you know, they'll usually call you to get a little background. Oh, is that why they called you? Yeah, yeah. So he was asking me to kind of fill in some of the blanks.
你有一个，他正在做这个，某种关于你的生平特写。所以，听众朋友们，当记者要为你的某个名人朋友做生平特写时，你知道的，他们通常会打电话来向你了解一些背景信息。哦，这就是他们打电话给你的原因？对，对。所以他让我帮忙填补一些空白。
No, it's cool. I was really well compensated for it. No. And it was, you know what? You know what I discovered, Sean? I had nothing planned to say. I found that it was very easy to say nice things about you. Oh, that's really sweet. You know, usually you have to kind of dig
不，这挺酷的。我为此得到了很好的报酬。并没有。而且，你知道吗？你知道我发现了什么，肖恩？我什么都没提前准备。我发现说你的好话简直易如反掌。哦，这太贴心了。你知道的，通常你得绞尽脑汁
for some flowery verse about a friend. And it just all fell out. They called and they said, would you be willing to say something for this piece about Sean? And I said, no, thank you. Yeah, because what did Mom tell you? If you don't have something nice?
去搜肠刮肚地找一些华丽的辞藻来赞美一个朋友。结果那些话就自然而然地涌出来了。他们打电话来说，你愿意为这篇关于肖恩的文章说点什么吗？我说，不，谢谢。对，因为妈妈是怎么教你的？如果你说不出什么好听的话……
Wait, do you know that Betty Davis thing from David Letterman? Did I tell you guys that? No, no. So I'm not going to get this read, but it's something like this. Betty Davis, like a year before she died, was on David Letterman and she, and David goes, so what was it like working with Joan Crawford and she and the audience laughed
等等，你知道大卫·莱特曼访谈里的那个贝蒂·戴维斯梗吗？我有跟你们说过吗？没有，没有。所以我可能记不太准了，但大概是这样的。贝蒂·戴维斯在她去世前大约一年，上了大卫·莱特曼的节目，然后大卫说，那么和琼·克劳馥合作是什么感觉，然后她和观众都笑了，
because he knew she, they knew he was kind of prying her, poking at her. And she goes, David, my mother always said to say something good about the dead. Joan Crawford's dead? Crawford's dead? Good.
因为大卫知道她，他们也知道大卫是在故意套她的话、逗她。然后她说：大卫，我母亲总是教导我们要说死者的好话。琼·克劳馥死了？克劳馥死了？太好了。
Wow. That's very well done. That's pretty great. I'll borrow that. I'll take that. Well, guys, can we segue while we're talking about legends? Sure. Oh my God, yeah.
哇。这段说得太棒了。太精彩了。我要借用一下。我要拿来用了。好了，各位，趁我们在聊传奇人物，能转个话题吗？当然。哦天呐，行啊。
Let's segue now. You know, we've got a fella today that we could learn a thing or two from. Hopefully he'll give us some pointers on career longevity, creative relevance, reinvention and overall swagger. He's in the music side
我们现在就转话题。你知道的，我们今天请到了一位我们能从他身上学到一两招的大咖。希望他能给我们传授一些关于如何保持职业长青、创意生命力、不断转型以及整体气场的小贴士。他是音乐界的
of show biz and has been one of the more recognized names around the world for as long as our parents have been alive. He has over 900 songs to his credit, recorded over 130 albums worldwide. His LP in single sales
大人物，而且自我们父母辈还活着的时候起，就一直是全世界最广为人知的名字之一。他名下有900多首歌曲，在全世界发行了130多张专辑。他的LP和单曲销量
collectively number more than 90 million and he is the only artist in history to have a song in the Billboard Top 100 during seven consecutive decades. He's a legend. Wait a minute. He's a friend and most importantly, be cool because he's my father-in-law.
加起来超过900万张，他也是历史上唯一一位在连续七个年代里都有歌曲打入公告牌百大单曲榜的艺术家。他是个传奇。等等。他还是个朋友，最重要的是，放尊重点，因为他是我岳父。
Oh my God. Oh my God. Dad. Can I talk and get rid of the cardboard? You can talk and get rid of the cardboard. There he is. There he is. Hi Pops.
哦天呐。哦天呐。爸爸。我可以说话并把那个纸板拿开吗？你可以说话并把纸板拿开。他来了。他来了。嗨，老爸。
Hello, I guess this is the end of the Canadian quota, right? Speaking of which, during my incredible research, do you know Will? He's got a day named after him in Canada. There's Paul Anka Day in Canada. What do you have?
你好，我想这是加拿大配额的尽头了吧？说到这个，在我那不可思议的研究过程中，你知道威尔吗？加拿大有一个以他名字命名的日子。加拿大有个“保罗·安卡日”。你有什么？
Do you have an hour or anything? There are a few tiers. Paul is like a few tiers above me in the Canadian hierarchy when it comes to legends. I have a long way to go. Paul, I can't believe, first of all, I can't believe that Jason and I have been friends
你有一个小时的时间还是别的什么？有好几个级别。在传奇人物的加拿大排资论辈中，保罗比我高出好几个级别。我还有很长的路要走。保罗，我简直不敢相信，首先，我不敢相信杰森和我已经是老朋友了，
for so long and this is the first time we've met. Is that true? I know. I've never met you either. We can say that about a lot of people. I know. Paul is a hard guy to nail down. He's always moving. He's always on the road. Where are you now? I'll bet you're not in LA.
而这是我们第一次见面。真的吗？我知道。我也从来没见过你。我们对很多人都可以这么说。我知道。保罗是个很难约到的人。他总是四处奔波。他总是在路上。你现在在哪儿？我敢说你不在洛杉矶。
I'm in Florida. I'm doing a tour. I just finished the Hard Rock Casino. I finished Palm Beach and I'm on my way to Naples on the completion of this wonderful event for me. What do you do? Do you still do about 30 weeks a year? I do about 70 days. That's all I want to do.
我在佛罗里达。我在做巡演。我刚结束在硬石赌场（Hard Rock Casino）的演出。我刚结束棕榈滩的演出，在完成对我来说这场美妙的活动后，我正赶往那不勒斯。你现在还做什么？你一年还做大约30周的演出吗？我做大约70天。这就是我想做的全部。
You've welcomed the 80s now, right? And you still... Will, you're not going to be moving at that age at all. It's so impressive. Paul, it should be noted that I like your son-in-law.
你现在已经迈入80岁了吧，对吧？而且你依然……威尔，到那个年纪你根本就动不了了。太令人印象深刻了。保罗，必须指出的是，我很喜欢你女婿。
I love your daughter. I'm in that. Yeah, I know. And I talked to her probably more than I talked to JB, thankfully. It's not probably. That's a definite. She talks so glowingly about how much,
我爱你女儿。我属于这一挂的。对，我知道。而且我跟她说话的次数可能比跟JB说话的次数还多，谢天谢地。这可不是“可能”。这是肯定的。她总是充满热情地谈论，
first of all, through her life, when she was little, but even now, how insanely busy you are and how... I'm going to say industrious, but you never stop moving. What is the secret to doing it for so long? To being able to have that kind of motor?
首先，在她小的时候，乃至现在的生活中，你是多么疯狂地忙碌，以及你是多么……我要用“勤奋”这个词，但你从不肯停下脚步。这么长时间以来一直保持这种状态的秘诀是什么？怎么能拥有那种源源不断的动力？
I guess. If you stop moving, will they throw dirt on you? That's number one. That's going to be our new logo. I've worked out for the age 16. And as long as you've got a passion for what you're doing
我想。如果你停下来，他们是不是就会往你身上扬土了？这是第一点。这将成为我们的新标志。我从16岁就开始健身了。只要你对自己正在做的事情充满激情，
and when you started the way that I did out of Canada, hey, as long as the dream's alive, the passion and the energy, you keep doing it. Unfortunately, you stop like I've seen many of my buddies do and you see a lot of TV, read a lot of books and die. So I love what I'm doing.
并且当你以我当年从加拿大开始的那种方式起步时，嘿，只要梦想还在，激情和能量还在，你就会继续做下去。不幸的是，如果你停下来，就像我看到我的许多死党那样，你就会看很多电视，读很多书然后死去。所以我热爱我正在做的事。
I'm constantly changing. I'm in the middle now of doing my documentary. We've got a Broadway show that we're doing with writers and it's just something that I love to do, man. When you leave Canada and you make it, you're really grateful because nothing was happening up there other than moose jerky
我一直在不断改变。我现在正忙着拍我的纪录片。我们有一个正在跟编剧合作的百老汇节目，这都是我热爱的事业，老兄。当你离开加拿大并闯出名堂时，你会非常感激，因为当我离开的时候，除了驼鹿肉干，那儿什么也没有发生。
when I left. Moose jerky. Hey, is that a thing? You guys don't know it. I respect all of you, obviously, but when I did start, there was no opportunity. When I get lucky as a kid, I leave Ottawa, you know what, 150,000 people
驼鹿肉干。嘿，那玩意儿真有吗？你们可能不知道。我显然尊重你们所有人，但当我刚开始的时候，根本没有什么机会。当我作为一个孩子走运离开渥太华时，你知道的，当时那里有15万人口，
at that time, and I hit and the luck's been continuing since then and I said, I'm not going to lose this and then you go through the Rat Pack in Vegas and the Mafia and you learn what to do, what not to do and then you say to yourself, you're being asked to really give this up.
我一炮而红，而且这份好运一直持续到现在，我对自己说，我绝不能失去这一切。然后你经历了拉斯维加斯的鼠党（Rat Pack）和黑手党，你懂得了该做什么，不该做什么，接着你对自己说，有人在要求你真正放弃这一切。
So that's pretty much been the motivation. First of all, I want to get into this. You come out of Ottawa, or as I used to refer to it, the town that fun forgot. I just never seen since. To all our fans in Ottawa,
所以这基本上一直是我的动力。首先，我想聊聊这个。你从渥太华出来，或者就像我以前称呼它的那样，一个被欢乐遗忘的小镇。我再也没见过。致我们在渥太华的所有粉丝，
I only say that as a Toronto Maple East fan. It's a joke, so relax, hold back your comments. But you come out of Ottawa, as we know, these guys don't know, the nation's capital in Canada, but a small town and you were, but you didn't do this, Paul, when you were
我这么说纯粹是因为我是多伦多枫叶队的球迷。这只是个玩笑，所以放松点，收起你们的评论吧。但正如我们所知（虽然这几位不知道），你走出了渥太华，那是加拿大的首都，但却是个小镇，而且保罗，你做这些的时候可不是在
25. Before the age of 18, he had five top 20 hits. Before what? Before 18? Before 18. This is what blows me away, Paul. Talk to us about how as a young guy, you had all this success.
25岁。在18岁之前，他就已经有五首打入前20名的热门单曲了。在什么之前？在18岁之前？在18岁之前。这就是让我震惊的地方，保罗。给我们讲讲，作为一个年轻人，你是如何取得这一切成功的。
It blows my mind. When I first read that years ago, I couldn't believe it. Well, you're 14, you're 15, you're in school, you're in grade 10 for two years, so you get the hint. Wait a second, you repeated 10th grade? Yeah, twice. So I'm in a class
这太让我震惊了。多年前我第一次读到这个时，简直不敢相信。好吧，你14岁，15岁，你在上学，你在10年级读了两年，所以你懂了吧。等等，你10年级留级了？对，两次。所以我在一个
with a bunch of girls with my friend Tommy, whose family were the big ski champs, and we wanted the quickest way out, so we took typing and shorthand. I got thrown out of a shorthand class and took music, so now I get interested in music.
全都是女孩的班级里，跟我朋友汤米一起，他家是滑雪冠军世家，我们想找最快的退学途径，于是我们选修了打字和速记。我被速记课开除了，然后选了音乐，所以我就这样对音乐产生了兴趣。
And one day I started writing poetry, and I win awards for my writing. I get thrown into a music class, I take piano lessons, and I start becoming this real big fan of all the rhythm and blue stuff. The black music experience, as it is now, drove everything back then,
有一天我开始写诗，我的写作还得了奖。我被塞进音乐课，上了钢琴课，然后我开始成为所有节奏布鲁斯（R&B）音乐的超级粉丝。黑人音乐体验，正如现在这样，在那时主导了一切，
as it did when back to the 30s. So I get hooked on music, and I just start writing away. Now I'm playing hockey like all of us attempted to do. I got tired of ducking, because I was very short, so I said, it's not in my future.
就像回到30年代时一样。所以我迷上了音乐，然后就开始不停地创作。现在我像我们所有人曾经尝试过的那样在打冰球。我厌倦了躲闪，因为我个子很矮，所以我觉得，这不在我的未来规划里。
And in my day, those guys didn't wear helmets, they didn't wear masks, they didn't wear masks on the rink, so you can imagine how dangerous it was. So they said it won't be hockey, so I'm going to just write songs. So I start writing songs. So I'm hooked, I'm loving the music.
在我那个年代，那些家伙不戴头盔，不戴面具，冰球场上不戴面具，所以你可以想象当时有多危险。所以他们说不会是冰球，那我就去写歌吧。于是我开始写歌。所以我迷上了，我热爱音乐。
I had a paper route, and then I got a job at IGA food stores, because I heard if you won the contest, you'd get to go to New York, where all the music was. Because the music business was in its infancy stage back there. There were not a lot of labels. What year is it?
我送过报纸，后来在IGA食品超市找了份工作，因为我听说如果你赢了比赛，就能去纽约，那是所有音乐的发源地。因为当时的音乐产业还处于萌芽阶段。没有多少唱片公司。那是哪一年？
I won the award for collecting soup wrappers for Campbell Soup. And me and 40 kids from across Canada put on a train with soggy sandwiches. 15 hours later, I met the YMCA in New York. I said, man, this is it.
我因为收集金宝汤（Campbell Soup）的汤罐头包装纸而赢得了奖项。我和来自全加拿大的40个孩子一起被塞进一列火车，吃着湿漉漉的三明治。15个小时后，我在纽约的基督教青年会（YMCA）下了车。我说，老兄，就是这儿了。
I'm coming back. So I go back home, and I said to my dad, look, give me some money. I had some saved up from my paper route. I'm going back to New York. I've got a connection to see a record company. And I go down, I walk into ABC Paramount Records,
我要再回来。于是我回到家，对我爸说，听着，给我点钱。我从送报纸的钱里存了一些。我要回纽约。我有个关系能见到一家唱片公司。然后我去了，走进ABC派拉蒙唱片公司（ABC Paramount Records），
which had ABC TV network just starting out. I sing for Don Costa. He was the A&R guy. And like all of us guys, success has a lot of fathers. And he was the guy that made it happen. He said, where are you from, blah, blah, blah, blah. I told him, he said, bring your parents down here.
当时他们的ABC电视网才刚起步。我为唐·科斯塔（Don Costa）唱歌。他是A&R（艺人与 repertory）负责人。就像我们所有人一样，成功有很多父亲。他就是那个让这一切成真的人。他说，你从哪儿来，巴拉巴拉巴拉。我告诉了他，他说，把你父母带到这儿来。
We want to sign you. You're too young. So I found my parents down. They signed a contract, and May of that year, I was in Atlanta. Two other songs. That was a song you wrote for the gal that didn't want to hear it. Right? Yeah.
我们想跟你签约。你太年轻了。于是我把我父母找来。他们签了合同，那年五月我就在亚特兰大了。另外两首歌。那是你写给那个不想听这首歌的女孩的歌。对吧？是的。
And then two or three months later, American Bandstand started. I'm on there in the Ed Sullivan show, and that was it. It took off from there and my life changed. Wait, wait, you did the Ed Sullivan show? I mean, yes. What was that like? How was that? Scared to death. Scared to death.
然后两三个月后，《美国舞台》（American Bandstand）开播了。我上了那个节目还有埃德·苏利文秀（The Ed Sullivan Show），然后就是这样。它从那里腾飞了，我的人生也改变了。等等，等等，你上了埃德·苏利文秀？我是说，对。那是什么感觉？怎么样？吓得半死。吓得半死。
Because that was like the biggest show then. Well, that was it. You know, television back then was three channels. I read in the middle and green on the bottom, and he tape it to the TV, and that was called a television. Come on. And Ottawa didn't start till five o'clock in the afternoon, and there was like news, a cooking show, and maybe wrestling once a week.
因为那是当时最大的节目。嗯，就是这样。你知道，那时的电视只有三个频道。中间是黑白的，底部带点绿色，你把它贴在电视机上，那就是所谓的电视机。别逗了。渥太华的电视节目要到下午五点才开始，基本上就是新闻、烹饪节目，可能一周还有一次摔跤。
I mean, it was not... And millions and millions and millions of people watching, because there were no other choices. Amazing. Well, it was all radio before that. I used to sit in Ottawa next to a radio and listen to everything until television came. God, am I aging myself? Could you imagine asking our kids
我是说，那可不是……而且有数以百万计的人在观看，因为没别的选择。太惊人了。好吧，在那之前全都是收音机。我以前坐在渥太华的收音机旁听各种节目，直到电视出现。天呐，我这是在暴露年龄吗？你能想象让我们的孩子们
to sit in front of a big box that has sound coming out of it and entertain yourself for a few hours just listening to it? No, they wouldn't do that. They'd look at us like we're nuts. No, obviously not now. But, you know, that's all that there was, right? Right, exactly.
坐在一个会发出声音的大盒子前面，光靠听声音自娱自乐几个小时吗？不，他们才不会这么干。他们会把我们当成疯子。不，现在当然不会了。但是，你知道的，以前就只有那些，对吧？对，没错。
So, like, it felt like... I got to be honest with you. I mean, obviously I grew up... I was born in 70, so it's not... But I do remember as a kid, on my clock radio, I was just talking about with my buddy, Eli. I used to be able to get the W... What was the station out of Buffalo when I could get Saber's games? Oh, yes, the bound dog, yes.
所以，就像，感觉……说实话。我的意思是，很显然我是伴随着……我出生于70年，所以不算……但我确实记得小时候，在我的床头收音机上，我刚跟我哥们儿伊利谈过这件事。我以前能收到W……布法罗的那个电台是什么来着，当时能听美洲狮队（Sabres）的比赛？哦，对，那条大狗，没错。
And I could get them on my... When I was told to go to bed, I could still hear the buffalo sing. As a Canadian, Paul, you know this. When you get that radio signal out of the states, it feels like a whole other world. You can't believe it, right? Everything came at you.
而且我可以通过我的……当我被勒令上床睡觉时，我依然能听到布法罗的歌声。作为加拿大人，保罗，你懂的。当你从美国接收到那个电台信号时，感觉就像是进入了另一个全新的世界。简直让人难以置信，对吧？一切都向你涌来。
There was nothing to watch. I mean, it was just so boring. There was nothing going on. I was listening to Fats Domino and everybody else. That takes off a bit. And then how... So that was your first number one hit? And your 14?
没什么可看的。我是说，实在是太无聊了。根本没什么娱乐活动。我当时在听胖子多米诺（Fats Domino）和其他所有人的歌。这开始走红了。然后怎么……所以那是你的第一首冠军单曲？当时你14岁？
First number one hit, yeah. And then what were the other four that were the five top 20s before you were 18? So at 15, you got Diana. Then my dad wanted me home and then a promoter called up and my second was
第一首冠军单曲，对。然后那五首在18岁之前进入前20名的另外四首是什么？所以15岁时，你有了《黛安娜》（Diana）。然后我爸想让我回家，接着有个演出经纪人打电话来，我的第二首是
you're my destiny, but my dad wanted me to finish school. And I talked the promoter and then let me live with him. He had a bunch of drug stores. Izzy and Irving fell. So with you on my destiny, I move in with them down in Washington.
《你是我的命运》（You're My Destiny），但我爸想让我完成学业。我和那个经纪人商量，让我住在他家。他有很多药店。伊斯齐和欧文·费尔（Izzy and Irving Fell）。所以伴随着《你是我的命运》，我搬去他们在华盛顿的住所和他们一起住。
Then I had those lonely boy, puppy love, I love you baby. There's a string of hits. Really quick, Paul. I'm doing a play here in New York and the guy who wrote it, Doug Wright and my other actress friend, Deb Monk wrote a song called Puppy Love Doggy Style.
然后我有了那些《孤独的男孩》（Lonely Boy）、《纯洁的爱》（Puppy Love）、《我爱你宝贝》（I Love You Baby）。有一连串的热门单曲。说个题外话，保罗。我正在纽约排一部话剧，写这部剧的家伙道格·赖特（Doug Wright）和我另一个女演员朋友黛布·蒙克（Deb Monk）写了一首歌叫《纯洁的爱：狗式情歌》（Puppy Love Doggy Style）。
I love that. Paul, we'll see them in court. I offered it to Frank Sinatra when I started working for the mob in Vegas. He wanted me to write for him and I said, well, I can give you a puppy love. We'll change it to love as a bitch. You know,
我喜欢这个。保罗，我们在法庭上见吧。当我开始在拉斯维加斯为黑帮做事时，我曾把这首歌献给弗兰克·辛纳特拉。他想让我为他写歌，我说，好吧，我可以给你一首《纯洁的爱》。我们把它改成《爱就是个婊子》。你知道的，
I was thrown into that world because I worked for the guys. I mean, a lot of people, they fantasize of what it was about, but it was real. They controlled everything. Talk a little bit about how that happened. How did you end up? Well, first of all, you wrote
我被卷入了那个世界，因为我是为那些大佬们工作的。我是说，很多人对那是怎样的生活充满幻想，但那是真实的。他们控制了一切。稍微讲讲那是怎么发生的吧。你最后是怎么……嗯，首先，你写了
a very popular song, one of the great songs of all time for Frank Sinatra. My way, yes. Well, that came later. You know what happened? You wrote My Way? I think so. You have me thinking about that.
一首非常受欢迎的歌，为弗兰克·辛纳特拉创作了有史以来最伟大的歌曲之一。我的路（My Way），是的。嗯，那是后来发生的。你知道发生了什么吗？你写了《我的路》？我想是的。你把我给说糊涂了。
I didn't know that. Let's go back before we get into My Way. Let's go back into how you start working with those guys and working with the mob. Well, I'm making lots of money and I've got lots of hits and everywhere that I had to play, the mob ran everything.
我不知道那首是我写的。在我们聊《我的路》之前，先回到你是怎么开始跟那些家伙合作并为黑帮工作的。好吧，我赚了很多钱，我有很多热门歌曲，而且我去表演的每个地方，黑帮都控制着一切。
They ran all the clubs, all the distributors, labels, all the restaurants. Which is the youngest to play Copacabana? Well, I became, with those hits, I became the youngest to work this mob place called the Copa, which was huge. Yeah.
他们控制了所有的俱乐部、所有的分销商、唱片公司、所有的餐厅。谁是去科帕卡巴纳俱乐部（Copacabana）演出的最年轻的人？嗯，凭借那些热门歌曲，我成了去这个叫科帕（Copa）的黑帮场馆工作的最年轻的人，那里规模巨大。对。
And I started working it as the youngest kid and I must have done weeks there on the block, Bob. I was about 19 years old. Well, I was in Vegas first. I played Vegas at 18 with Sophie Tucker. And then America's favorite group.
我开始以最年轻的小子的身份在那里演出，我肯定在那里驻唱了好几个星期，鲍勃。我当时大约19岁。嗯，我先进的维加斯。我在18岁时和索菲·塔克（Sophie Tucker）一起在维加斯演出。然后是全美最受欢迎的组合。
And from there, I went to the Copacabana in New York and I started there very, very young and I had a bunch of hits going into that and then the bosses said, would you like to go work Vegas with the rat pack? Now, you know that these guys are in the mob
从那里，我去了纽约的科帕卡巴纳俱乐部，我在那里开始得很早很早，带着一堆热门歌曲去了那里，然后老板们说，你想不想去维加斯和鼠党一起工作？现在，你知道这些家伙是黑帮
at this point. You totally know who you're working for. You're told to behave yourself. Wow. These are the guys and when you see them, blah, blah, blah. I mean, there's this real strict education as to behavior, what to wear, how to act.
在这个节点上。你完全知道你在为谁工作。你被告知要守规矩。哇。这些就是那些家伙，当你看到他们时，巴拉巴拉巴拉。我是说，关于行为举止、穿衣打扮、如何行事，有着非常严格的教育。
Me, Bobby Darren, Frankie Avalon. So we knew who we were working for. Uh-huh. When the word came out, go to Vegas, I fly out there, spent a lot of time there, you know, saw Sinatra, Marilyn Monroe, that whole thing. And I start working for the boys
我和、鲍比·达林（Bobby Darren）、弗兰基·阿瓦隆（Frankie Avalon）。所以我们知道我们在为谁工作。嗯哼。当消息传来，去维加斯吧，我飞过去，在那里度过了很多时间，你知道的，见到了辛纳特拉、玛丽莲·梦露，诸如此类。然后我开始为这帮大佬工作，
and with the rat pack at the Sands Hotel. What year is this? That's 1961, 62 somewhere in there. You're too young to gamble. Couldn't go in the building. I had to look through the windows until I was old enough at 21.
并且在金沙酒店（Sands Hotel）和鼠党一起演出。这是哪一年？那是1961年、62年左右吧。你太年轻了，还不能赌博。都不能进大楼。我只能透过窗户往里看，直到我21岁到了法定年龄。
You didn't have a fake idea or something like that to get in there? He's famous. He's Paul Anke at this point. Those guys knew everything. They knew everything of who was in there, who was allowed in, who wasn't. I would have died so quickly if I was part of the mob because I always thought
你当时没有搞个假身份证什么的混进去吗？他很有名。那时候他可是保罗·安卡。那些家伙什么都知道。谁在里面，谁被允许进去，谁不能进去，他们一清二楚。如果我是黑帮的一员，我早就死得快极了，因为我总是觉得
it would be so cool. But like, oh, these guys are like, I don't know, there's something glamorous about that life that I think everybody would say. You would have been like that annoying dog in the cartoons, just run circles around, the big dog.
那一定很酷。但是，哦，这些家伙就像是，我不知道，那种生活有某种迷人的魅力，我想每个人都会这么说。你当时就会像动画片里那只烦人的小狗，围着大狗团团转。
Where are we going? What are you guys talking about now? You meeting the mob would immediately be, the scene would be you meeting them and immediately all those guys doing one of those funny scenes about how they're going to bury you, where they're going to bury you. Who's going to bury your stupid mob?
我们要去哪儿？你们现在在聊什么？你遇到黑帮的场景立刻就会变成：你遇到他们，然后那帮家伙立刻开始搞那种搞笑的场景，讨论他们要怎么把你埋了，要把你埋在哪儿。谁会把你的蠢黑帮埋了？
And we knew. Listen, it was such a small community. You knew when somebody got smoked. Wow. You know, when a game was rigged. Were you ever scared about that? No, ever. I'm scared going there now. I'm scared going to Vegas now with what's there.
而且我们心里有数。听着，那是个非常小的圈子。有人被“做掉”了，你是会知道的。哇。你知道的，什么时候比赛被操纵了。你当时害怕过吗？不，从来没有。我现在去那里才害怕。我现在去维加斯看到那里的情况，我都害怕。
Believe me, you can't trust anything that's going on there now from the streets to your room. Really? And we will be right back. We'll be right back. One of your top choices. And they'll be more likely to apply.
相信我，现在那里发生的一切，从街道到你的房间，你什么都不能相信。真的吗？我们马上回来。我们马上回来。你的顶级选择之一。他们申请的可能性也会更高。
Invite Zipper Cooter to be your hiring platform. Four out of five employers who post on Zipper Cooter get a quality candidate within the first day. See for yourself. Go to this exclusive web address to try Zipper Cooter for free. Zipper Cooter dot com slash smart list. Again, that's Zipper Cooter dot com
邀请ZipRecruiter作为你的招聘平台。在ZipRecruiter发布招聘信息的雇主中，五分之四的人在第一天就能找到优质候选人。亲自体验一下吧。前往这个专属网址免费试用ZipRecruiter。ZipRecruiter点com斜杠smart list。再重复一遍，那是ZipRecruiter点com
slash S M A R T L E S S. Zipper Cooter the smartest way to hire. SmartList is sponsored by BetterHelp. As a lot of you know, I'm in New York doing a show on Broadway and it can take a lot out of you. So what I do is I figure out how to balance my time doing the show
斜杠S M A R T L E S S。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。SmartList由BetterHelp赞助。正如你们很多人所知，我正在纽约出演一档百老汇演出，这真的很消耗精力。所以我所做的，就是摸索如何在演出的同时平衡好时间，
with taking care of myself because I think it's very important to take care of yourself after you're working whatever your job is. And some people find that selfish. I don't. You have to take care of yourself so that you can be there for yourself. I don't.
还要照顾好自己，因为我认为在完成工作——无论你的工作是什么——之后照顾好自己非常重要。有些人觉得这很自私。我不这么认为。你必须照顾好自己，这样你才能为自己负责。我不这么认为。
You have to take care of yourself so that you can be there for other people, family members, and all your loved ones. So it's easy to get caught up in what everyone else needs from you and never take a moment to think about what you need from yourself. But when we spend all of our time giving,
你必须照顾好自己，这样你才能够照顾其他人、家庭成员以及你所有的挚爱。所以人们很容易陷入满足其他人对你的需求，却从来不花时间去想你自己需要什么。但当我们把所有的时间都用来付出时，
it can leave us feeling stretched thin and burnt out. Therapy can give you the tools to find more balance in your life so you can keep supporting others without leaving yourself behind. I've done a ton of these ads and I really believe in therapy.
这会让我们感到筋疲力尽、精疲力竭。疗愈可以为你提供工具，在生活中找到更多平衡，这样你就可以继续支持他人，而不会抛下自己。我做过成百上千个这样的广告，我是真的很相信心理咨询。
It really, really does help. It helps you figure out how to balance everything we're talking about, being there for other people so you can be there for yourself and vice versa. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient,
它真的、真的很有用。它能帮你想清楚如何平衡我们所谈论的一切——既能照顾到别人也能照顾到自己，反之亦然。如果你正在考虑开始心理咨询，不妨试试BetterHelp。它完全在网上进行，旨在为你提供便利，
flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelpHELP.com slash smartLess. This episode is brought to you in part
灵活，并且适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，就能与有执照的治疗师进行匹配，随时更换治疗师，并且你的第一个月可以享受10折优惠。网址是BetterHelpHELP.com斜杠smartLess。本期节目部分内容由
by Benjamin Moore. We all love a beautiful home, but messes our part of home life and it's great having a high quality paint that can stand up to everything from kids to dogs and everything in between. With Benjamin Moore's premium colors, you can see the difference.
Benjamin Moore（本杰明摩尔油漆）赞助播出。我们都喜欢美丽的家，但生活难免会弄出脏乱，拥有一款经得起从孩子到狗狗以及各种考验的高品质涂料真是太棒了。使用Benjamin Moore的优质色彩，你能看出其中的差别。
They have a whole team dedicated to ensuring best-in-class formulations that are better, stronger, and simpler. So recently, one of our producers, Rob and his wife, Dreya, have been doing a little poosing up around their house. One of the projects they just completed is refinishing their backyard deck
他们拥有一个专门的团队，致力于确保最好、最强、最简单的配方。最近，我们的制作人罗布（Rob）和他的妻子德雷亚（Dreya）一直在给他们的房子做点小小的翻新。他们刚刚完成的项目之一，就是重新粉刷他们的后院露台
and their front gate just in time for backyard summer hangouts. Enter Benjamin Moore paints. It was super easy. They just grabbed a bunch of swatches and put them up, a charming spot called Jill's Paints in Atwater Village, just a little plug,
和前门大门，正好赶上后院的夏日聚会。有请Benjamin Moore油漆。这超级简单。他们只是在阿特沃特村（Atwater Village）一家叫做吉尔油漆（Jill's Paints）的迷人小店里抓了一堆色卡比划了一下——顺便打个小广告，
and ended up using a specialized floor and patio paint for their deck that holds up to foot traffic and the elements. And for their gate, they use Benjamin Moore's heritage line, which is formulated specifically for exteriors. And guess what?
最后他们的露台选用了一种专门的地板和露台油漆，能够经受住人流踩踏和各种天气的考验。而对于大门，他们使用了Benjamin Moore的传承系列（Heritage line），该系列专门为户外设计。你猜怎么着？
The result is absolutely stunning. Gorgeous. Benjamin Moore paint is only sold for purchase at Benjaminmoore.com using code SmartLess. That's Benjaminmoore.com code SmartLess. And now, back to the show. What would be the main thing
效果绝对惊艳。美极了。Benjamin Moore油漆仅在Benjaminmoore.com独家销售，使用优惠码SmartLess。网址是Benjaminmoore.com，优惠码SmartLess。现在，让我们回到节目中。与黑帮交谈时，
that you would have to watch out to not do when you're conversing with the mob? Like, what would be... What would get you in trouble? Well, respect was everything. What you said was everything. You never wanted to
你必须小心翼翼不要去做的主 要事情是什么？比如，什么会是……什么会给你带来麻烦？嗯，尊重是一切。你所说的话就是一切。你绝对不能
get out of line or do anything in destroying a room, trying to do something that was out of line. You've got to remember, all these guys were older than I was. The Rat Pack were older. Carl Cohen was my rabbi. And Carl Cohen was the guy out at Cleveland. He was the sweetest guy ever.
越界或者把场子搞砸，试图去做一些越界的事。你得记住，所有这些家伙都比我大。鼠党的人比我大。卡尔·科恩（Carl Cohen）是我的精神导师。卡尔·科恩是克利夫兰的那个人。他是我见过最好的人。
And he watched over me. Those were the guys. Were they, like, father figures and brother's type? Yes, totally, totally. And Carl Cohen, he was the guy... He jumped ahead that knocked the teeth out of Frank Sinatra. Oh, wow. This is a rabbi.
他照顾我。就是那些家伙。他们就像是父亲和兄长那样的人吗？是的，完全是，完全是。而且卡尔·科恩，他就是那个……他挺身而出，把弗兰克·辛纳特拉的牙齿都打掉了。哦，哇。这是个导师。
Rabbi lit up Sinatra. This was Carl Cohen. And he was the nicest, salt-of-the-earth type of guy. And every time I needed something or had a problem, I would go to Carl Cohen and he would watch over me. Because I was this kid. But I was making money for them.
导师把辛纳特拉给揍了。这就是卡尔·科恩。他是个最好、最脚踏实地的人。每次我需要什么或者遇到麻烦时，我都会去找卡尔·科恩，他会照顾我。因为我当时还是个孩子。但我是在为他们赚钱。
It was very freaky for them because they were used to Sinatra, Dean Martin and Sammy Davis. And all of a sudden, this kid is wandering around doing business singing these cockamamie songs. You know, they're doing Cold Porter and I'm going, I'm so young and you're so old. Right. So then the rap pack, they're what?
对他们来说这太怪异了，因为他们习惯了弗兰纳特、迪恩·马丁和萨米·戴维斯。而突然之间，这个小伙子四处转悠，做着生意，唱着这些荒唐的歌。你知道的，他们唱着科尔·波特的歌，而我却在唱我太年轻你太老。没错。所以鼠党他们是什么？
They're in their mid-30s, 40s? Oh, yeah. You're hitting 20? I would say close to 40s, yeah. And were they welcoming to you? How long did it take for them to kind of bring you under their wing and kind of show you the ropes a little bit? Right away. See, they all had a vested interest
他们三十多岁、四十岁？哦，是啊。你那时候二十岁？我觉得快四十岁了，对。他们对你友好吗？他们花了多长时间才把你纳入羽翼之下，教你一些规矩？马上。你看，他们都有既得利益。
in whatever sense. And anybody that made money for them, you know, they had the swagger. Those were the guys. Sinatra made Las Vegas, all those guys. Everybody showed up only because of him and then the gambling. So when I hit the scene and I'm making money
某种意义上。任何能为他们赚钱的人，你知道，他们都有那种傲气。那些就是大人物。辛纳屈造就了拉斯维加斯，所有人都是。每个人出现都只是因为他，还有赌博。所以当我崭露头角，而且我为黑手党
for the mob, the word is out, be nice to the kid. That was my nickname, the kid. And we'd all hang out in the steam room, this little steam room, in the back of the hotel. In the back of our robes, we had our nicknames. You know, Sammy was smoking the bear. Dylan was Dino.
赚钱时，消息就传开了，对这小子好点。那是我的绰号，这小子。我们都会在蒸汽房里闲逛，这个小蒸汽房，在酒店后面。在我们的长袍后面，都有我们的绰号。你知道的，萨米是抽烟的熊。迪伦是迪诺。
My name was Dino. And they embraced me right away. Right away. And I just watched and learned. Watched and learned. They were amazing. That education that I got at those early years you couldn't get today.
我的名字叫迪诺。他们立刻接纳了我。立刻。我就只是观察和学习。观察和学习。他们太棒了。我在那些早年学到的东西，今天是学不到的。
There was no technology, no tricks. It was all real stuff. And those guys were the real deal. It was fun, fun, fun and professionalism. I learned so much from those guys. And then how did, not to jump too far ahead, but then how did my way come around for you to deliver to Sinatra?
那时候没有科技，没有花招。全都是真材实料。那些人都是货真价实的大佬。那真是充满乐趣、乐趣、乐趣和专业精神。我从那些家伙身上学到了太多。然后，怎么，不是要扯得太远，但后来你是怎么想出把《我的方式》交个辛纳屈唱的？
Well, you know, for years in there he had always teased me about writing for him. I'm still young. I'm scared to death. I'm intimidated. And I figured if I'm ever going to write something, it better be good because that'll be my one shot. But I'm in my early 20s. And I moved to Italy and I'm living over there
嗯，你知道的，多年来他一直在那里拿我开玩笑，让我为他写歌。我还很年轻。我吓得要死。我很恐慌。我想如果我要写什么东西，最好写好点，因为那将是我唯一的机会。但我才二十出头。我搬到了意大利，并在那边生活
because the Beatles hit, which I'll tell you that later. I got them over here. And I come back and I'm still working. And in the late 60s, we're down in Florida at the Fountain Blue Hotel. And that was a hang place for all of us and all the mob guys, the Fountain Blue, which was the model for Vegas, by the way.
因为披头士火了，我待会儿会告诉你们这个。我把他们带到这儿来的。然后我回来，我还在工作。60年代末，我们在佛罗里达的枫丹白露酒店。那是我们所有人和所有黑帮分子聚集的地方，枫丹白露，顺便说一句，它是拉斯维加斯的模板。
Ceasus Palace, Steve Wynn, all those guys learned from the aesthetics of the Fountain Blue Hotel in Miami. That's where that preacher guy, his wife got that pool boy from there. I just watched that documentary about it. It was the Fountain Blue. Unrelated, unrelated.
凯撒宫，史蒂夫·韦恩，所有这些家伙都是从迈阿密枫丹白露酒店的美学中吸取经验的。就是那个传道人的妻子从那里找来泳池男孩的地方。我刚看过关于它的纪录片。就是枫丹白露。无关，无关。
So, oh yeah, good friend. So the preacher boy, he was also around. I'm covering everybody here today. So I met the Fountain Blue. Wait, wait, wait, go back. What was the foundation of Vegas? Well, Steve Wynn, who's responsible for the, let's call it,
所以，哦，对，好朋友。所以那个传道男孩，他也在周围。我今天把所有人都覆盖到了。所以我遇到了枫丹白露。等等，等等，等等，回去。拉斯维加斯的基础是什么？嗯，史蒂夫·韦恩，他负责，我们称之为，
the second chapter of Las Vegas. Genius of Steve Wynn. He and the guy at Circus Circus and the mob who went all the money, the Teamsters Union, they were going to build Ceasus Palace. And I had 5% of Ceasus
拉斯维加斯的第二篇章。史蒂夫·韦恩的天才。他和马戏马戏酒店的人以及拥有所有钱的黑手党，卡车司机工会，他们打算建造凯撒宫。我拥有凯撒宫5%的股份
because my friend, Nate Jacobson, out of Baltimore, came to me who I'd invested with and he said, blah, blah, blah, we're going to build this hotel. We want you to be a part of it. Well, my people said you don't want to own anything because the governor will be all over you. So they all wanted to build this amazing hotel,
因为我的朋友内特·雅各布森，来自巴尔的摩，找到了我，我和他一起投资过，他说，巴拉巴拉巴拉，我们要建这家酒店。我们想让你成为其中的一部分。嗯，我的人说你什么都不要拥有，因为州长会找你麻烦。所以他们都想建这家惊人的酒店，
Ceasus Palace. How are we going to build it? What's it going to look like? The model, the aesthetic model and everything in it was taken out of the Mountain Blue Hotel, the inspiration for that aesthetic look of Ceasus, which was the cheapest
凯撒宫。我们该怎么建？它会是什么样子？它的模型、美学模型以及其中的一切都是从枫丹白露酒店里拿出来的，那是凯撒宫美学风格的灵感来源，那是全国房地产中最便宜的投资，
investment in real estate and the biggest bang of real estate in the country. It only cost them about $18 million if you can believe it. Ceasers? To build it, yeah. So anyway, so there I am in Florida, Sinatra's having dinner, invites me to dinner.
也是房地产中最震撼的一笔。如果你敢相信的话，他们只花了大约1800万美元。凯撒宫？建造它，对。所以无论如何，我在佛罗里达，辛纳屈在吃晚饭，邀请我共进晚餐。
I think he's running with Mia Farrell at the time. And he told me, he said, you know, I'm quitting show business. I'm tired. Rat Packs over. I've had enough of this and I'm going to rest. I'm doing one more album with Don Costa. Don Costa, as I mentioned earlier,
我想他当时正和米亚·法罗交往。他告诉我，他说，你知道的，我要退出娱乐圈了。我累了。鼠党结束了。我受够了，我要休息了。我和唐·科斯塔合作最后一张专辑。唐·科斯塔，正如我之前提到的，
was my producer. And I introduced him to Sinatra in the 60s and he did that amazing album, Sinatra and Strings. And he said, I'm quitting, but I'm doing one more album. He never wrote me a song. So I can't believe it. Sinatra quitting. So I go back to New York where I'm living at the time.
是我的制作人。我在60年代把他介绍给了辛纳屈，他制作了那张惊人的专辑《辛纳屈与弦乐》。他说我要退出了，但我还要做最后一张专辑。他从来没给我写过歌。所以我简直不敢相信。辛纳屈要退出。所以我回到我当时居住的纽约。
I sit at my piano, 12 midnight, thunderstorm outside. I'm saying Sinatra retiring. I can't believe it. I sit at my typewriter, paid off from sitting in grade 10 for two years and I'm typing away metaphorically. And now the end is years.
我坐在钢琴前，午夜12点，外面雷雨交加。我说辛纳屈要退休了。我简直不敢相信。我坐在打字机前，因为在十年级坐了两年而付清了代价，我元芳式地疯狂打字。而现在终点已近。
In five hours, I finished the song. That's crazy. So now I call him up at Caesar's and I said, sir, I said, I've got the song, blah, blah, blah. He said, bring it out. I fly out to Caesar's Palace. Go to his dressing room. I'm going to do the song. He says, kid, I love it.
在五个小时内，我完成了这首歌。这太疯狂了。于是我打电话给凯撒宫对他说，先生，我说，我写好歌了，巴拉巴拉巴拉。他说，拿来吧。我飞到凯撒宫。走进他的化妆室。我把这首歌唱给他听。他说，孩子，我太喜欢了。
I'm going to do it. Two months later, he calls me from a record studio in LA. Listen to this kid and he takes the phone and he puts it up to his speaker and I hear my way for the first time. How old are you? 25 years old. I'm not kidding. I'm getting chills.
我要录这首歌。两个月后，他从洛杉矶的一家录音室打电话给我，听听这个孩子，然后他拿起电话贴在扬声器上，我第一次听到了《我的方式》。你当时多大？25岁。我没开玩笑。我起鸡皮疙瘩了。
That's amazing. So the lyrics were quite literal that you just took. It's like, you know, for me, the end is near from his telling you what he's done. Exactly. Metaphoric. I wrote it as if he were writing it. Otherwise, it would never use ate it up
太惊人了。所以歌词相当直白，就是你拿来的那些。就像，你知道的，对我来说，终点已近，根据他告诉你的他所做过的事情。没错。隐喻。我写的时候就好像是由他来写的一样。否则，绝不会用吃干抹净
and spit it out and stuff like that. But that's very indigenous to Sinatra style. That blows my mind in a way that and that gate, like I said, it quite literally gave me chills and then the chills were gone when Sid Vicious recorded it. Years later.
然后吐掉之类的话。但那是极具辛纳屈风格的。这让我大开眼界，就像我说的，它真的让我起鸡皮疙瘩，然后当席德·维瑟斯录制它时，鸡皮疙瘩就消失了。多年以后。
I felt more than chills when I first heard it. So says he called and they said, we're using this Sid Vicious. I'd never heard the record. Is this a prank? He says, no, this is a real guy. So I heard it. I did some investigating. I said, you know, the guy was sincere. He went to Paris.
我第一次听到它的时候感觉到的不仅仅是鸡皮疙瘩。所以他说他打了电话，他们说，我们要用这个席德·维瑟斯。我从来没听过这张唱片。这是个恶作剧吗？他说，不，这是个真人。所以我听了。我做了一些调查。我说，你知道，这家伙很真诚。他去了巴黎。
He was ripping up amps and trying to get the sound. I said, who am I to stand in the way of someone's expression of a song? And I granted the license. That was so crazy. Jason, you know about that, right? That Sid Vicious from the Sex Pistols recorded my way. Yeah, yeah.
他在砸 amplifiers（音箱），试图弄出那个声音。我说，我算老几，怎么能挡别人的歌曲表达呢？我批准了授权。太疯狂了。杰森，你知道这事吧，对吧？性手枪乐队的席德·维瑟斯录制了《我的方式》。对，对。
I wonder if our listener does. That classic, that opening shot in Goodfellas that long tracking that not tracking steady cam shot through the kitchen and all this other stuff. That was a shot Scorsese came up with as a result
我不知道我们的听众知不知道。那个经典镜头，《好家伙》里开场那个长跟拍，那个不是跟拍，是通过厨房以及所有其他东西的斯坦尼康稳拍镜头。那是斯科塞斯想出来的镜头，起因是
of watching a documentary about Paul where a handheld camera followed him all the way through a kitchen, right? And then up on the stage. Yes, Paul, is that right? I produced a film with the national film board. You guys know how important their work is. And they came to me
看了关于保罗的纪录片，手持摄像机一路跟着他穿过厨房，对吧？然后走上舞台。是的，保罗，是这样吗？我与国家电影局合作制作了一部电影。你们知道他们的工作有多重要。他们找到我
in the early 60s. We want to do this documentary first time ever on a pop artist, blah, blah, blah. I said, let's do it. So we did it and we won a lot of awards the Venice Award and New York Critic Awards and it became this really acclaimed piece of
在60年代初。我们想拍这部纪录片，历史上第一次拍流行艺人，巴拉巴拉巴拉。我说，干吧。于是我们拍了，并赢得了许多奖项，威尼斯奖和纽约影评人奖，它成了这是一部广受赞誉的
Verité on a pop artist and Scorsese used it, the Beatles used it in terms of the application and how it was directed, etc. It was taken from the Copa Cabana. I used to do scene study with this guy, Vito Aniforma, the former boxer
关于流行艺人的真实电影，斯科塞斯借鉴了它，披头士也在应用和导演方式等方面借鉴了它，等等。它是从科帕卡巴纳拿来的。我曾经和这个家伙维托·阿尼福马一起做过场景研究，他曾是一名拳击手
and he's in that shot at the very end when Ray Liotta comes in and Ray Liotta says hey to him and he says hey. Anyway, he used to be my scene study partner years ago. I want to know Jason and Paul at what point, Jason after you met your
他在雷·利奥塔进来的那个镜头最后出现了，雷·利奥塔跟他说嗨，他也说嗨。无论如何，他多年前曾是我的场景研究搭档。我想知道杰森和保罗，在哪个时间点，杰森在你遇到了你
gorgeous, amazing, wonderful incredible wife Amanda did you go, oh my god, your dad is Paul Anka and then you're thinking, oh my god my father-in-law is Paul Anka and I'll never live up to, oh sorry.
美丽、惊艳、绝妙、不可思议的妻子阿曼达之后，你会不会想，哦我的天，你爸爸是保罗·安卡，然后你会想，哦我的天，我的岳父是保罗·安卡，我永远无法达到，哦抱歉。
And then at what point did it go away where you're just like, okay I can't stay in this frame of mind anymore and I'm just like, that's my dad. I knew because I knew her name when I met her when she introduced herself I was like
然后在那之后，在哪个时间点这种感觉消失了，以至于你只是觉得，好吧，我不能再保持这种心态了，我只是觉得，那就是我爸爸。我知道，因为当我遇到她时我知道她的名字，当她做自我介绍时我就想
oh, I don't remember if I even asked if she was related, I think I just assumed and so I was, I thought well if this goes a couple of more dates I might get to meet this guy and I'll be nervous about that. And then I think Paul was the first time
哦，我不记得我是否问过她是否有亲戚关系，我想我只是默认了，所以我是，我想如果再约会几次我可能会见到这家伙，我会为此感到紧张。然后我想保罗是第一次
we met at the Plaza Athene in New York I feel like it might be. Yeah, first and then you hung at the house up in Mulholland. Yeah, Jason remembers that but no vacation with his friend Sean go ahead Jay. No. With his french lot.
我们在纽约雅典娜广场酒店见面，我感觉可能是。对，第一次，然后你在穆荷兰的房子里闲逛。对，杰森还记得，但没有和他朋友肖恩一起度假，说吧，杰。不。和他的一群法国朋友。
He does remember the glory holes either for months. He put me to ease very, very quickly. He's obviously very used to being famous and having people be intimidated when they meet him and so he's got that down where he just disarms
他确实记得那些荣耀洞，几个月来一直如此。他让我非常非常快地放松下来。他显然非常习惯成名，习惯人们在见到他时感到畏缩，所以他很擅长这一点，他只是解除了
any kind of arm situation you might create you know, he's just as you can tell. Paul, I mean the way that you talk about these incredible, iconic not just people but moments in time and eras that you
你可能会制造的任何武装情况，你知道的，他就是那样，正如你所看到的。保罗，我是说你谈论这些不可思议的、标志性的不仅是人，还有你经历过的
inhabited. You were just an observer you were part of. You alluded to the fact that you were in Europe with the because of the Beatles or they were big at the time. Talk a little bit about that. Well I'm writing away but I'm realizing while I'm in the business all I kept hearing is
时间和时代的态度。你不仅是一个观察者，你还是其中的一部分。你暗示过因为披头士或者因为他们当时很大，你在欧洲。稍微谈谈那个吧。嗯，我一直在写歌，但我发现在我从事这个行业的同时，我一直听到的是
this may not last. They come and they go. They come and they go and they say, yeah, they may not last. Okay. I might be back sucking on that moose jerking in Canada in two years. So now I said, well I got to start writing songs for other people.
这可能不会持久。他们来来去去。他们来来去去，他们说，是的，这可能不会持久。好吧。两年后我可能又得回加拿大去吸那里的驼鹿肉干了。所以现在我说，好吧，我得开始为其他人写歌了。
Because I was a writer. I wasn't sold as a, you know, they groomed me up to look cute but I was not a good looking guy. But your voice is undeniable. Well, at least we had the voice going for us. So I'm singing away and I started writing for other people. I wrote Buddy Holly's Last Hit. It doesn't matter
因为我是一个作家。我没有被当作一个，你知道的，他们把我打扮得很可爱，但我不是个长得好看的人。但你的声音是无可否认的。好吧，至少我们的声音还不错。所以我一边唱歌一边开始为别人写歌。我写了巴迪·霍利的最后一首热门单曲。没关系了
anymore. And, you know, we lost him on one of our tours in the plane crash. And it started there. And then I'm writing for Connie Francis. Then I go to Europe and I'm asked to be in a movie called The Longest Day for Darrell F. Zannick. Classic war film. I'm in the film and look, I'm not an actor
而且，你知道的，我们在一次巡演中因飞机失事失去了他。一切就从那里开始。然后我为康妮·弗朗西斯写歌。接着我去欧洲，达里尔·F·扎纳克邀请我出演一部名为《最长的一天》的电影。经典的战争电影。我参演了这部电影，听着，我不是演员
but I'm in the film and I say to Zannick, hey, I'm a writer. I'm a writer. I'm telling everybody. I'm a writer. You need a song. I mean, open the fridge. The light went on. I'll write for you. So now with Zannick I go home. I'm inspired. I write The Longest Day for the film. Then I meet a guy called Johnny Carson.
但我参演了，我对扎纳克说，嘿，我是个作家。我是个作家。我告诉每个人。我是个作家。你需要一首歌。我是说，打开冰箱。灯亮了。我为你写。所以现在我和扎纳克一起回家。我受到了启发。我为电影写了《最长的一天》。然后我遇到了一个叫约翰尼·卡森的家伙。
He's starting this TV show for a year. I said, but I want a new song. I write the Tonight Show theme. You're joking, man. Wait a minute, Sean. Wait a minute. You're joking me. That is crazy. I wish I were to put Amanda through school until Jason
他要开办这个持续一年的电视节目。我说，但我想要一首新歌。我写了《今夜秀》的主题曲。你在开玩笑，老兄。等等，肖恩。等等。你在跟我开玩笑。这太疯狂了。我真希望我能让阿曼达完成学业，直到杰森
took both. It's the most recognized TV theme song in history. It's been performed a million times. You wrote that song. Well, let me tell you, writing is one thing, but getting it out there, I got thrown off
把两个都拿走。这是历史上辨识度最高的电视主题曲。它已经被演奏了上百万次。你写了那首歌。好吧，我告诉你，写作是一回事，但把它推向世界，我曾被
from Mitch Skitch Henderson was a part of the show and when Johnny came in, who was new and I'd given him a job on my TV show, Johnny, Skitch Henderson said, I don't want some kid taken over here. We're not
米奇·斯奇奇·亨德森赶走，他是节目的一部分，当约翰尼进来时，他是个新人，我曾在我的电视节目中给他安排过工作，斯奇奇·亨德森说，我不想让某些小孩来这里接管。我们不
using the song. And when Johnny called me and said, you know, I'm sorry, I love it, but I can't use it because Skitch has been here blah, blah, blah. He said, yeah, Skitch the switch artist. So I said to Johnny,
用这首歌。当约翰尼打电话给我说，你知道，我很抱歉，我很喜欢，但我不能用它，因为斯奇奇一直在巴拉巴拉巴拉。他说，是的，斯奇奇这个两面三刀的家伙。所以我对约翰尼说，
I said, look, I'll give you half the song, half the publishing, half the writing, and if anything happens, you're going to earn half of everything with me. So a day goes by and he calls up with his manager and says, you got it. Now they don't know it's going to be on what, 30 years?
我说，听着，我把一半的歌给你，一半的版权，一半的创作权，如果有什么事发生，你将和我平分一切。于是过了一天，他和他的经理打来电话说，成交了。现在他们还不知道这会播多少年，比如30年？
Either did I. So he says, the song is back on. And every night we listened to for what 30 years and I gave half the song away, but I had nothing anyway. Well, you had half of half of something instead of a hundred percent. And then Skitch went on to be
我也不知道。所以他说，这首歌又回来了。然后每天晚上我们听了30年，而我把一半的歌白送了，但我本来什么也没有。好吧，你拥有某样东西的一半的一半，总比百分之百没有强。然后斯奇奇后来成了
Sean's haircut, right Sean? What's his name? Skitcho. Skitcho. Skitcho. Go Skitcho. I go to Europe and I had a whole career in Europe. I went to Japan when I was 18. Yeah, what's this? You lived in Italy, you just said.
肖恩的发型师，对吧，肖恩？叫什么来着？斯奇奇。斯奇奇。斯奇奇，上吧。我去欧洲，我在欧洲拥有整个职业生涯。我18岁时去了日本。对，这是怎么回事？你住在意大利，你刚才说的。
Yeah, I lived in Italy. I didn't know that. Everything, well, when the Beatles hit, you know, let me go to that. I'm working the Olympia Theater and I'm really loving the culture and I'm loving Europe and I'm touring all over the place from Japan to Europe. And I go to see a friend of mine at the Olympia.
对，我住在意大利。我不知道那件事。每件事，嗯，当披头士火的时候，你知道，让我讲到那儿。我在奥林匹亚剧院工作，我真的很喜欢那种文化，我喜欢欧洲，我在世界各地巡演，从日本到欧洲。我去看我在奥林匹亚的一个朋友。
And on the under bill from my friend, he says, the Beatles. Watch your mic, Paul, you hitting the microphone. Oh, I says the Beatles, the Beatles. So I'm sitting there watching the show and the guy, ladies and gentlemen, he's the Beatles. And these guys come on and they're doing these cover songs.
在我的朋友的暖场名单上，他说，披头士。注意你的麦克风，保罗，你碰到麦克风了。哦，我说披头士，披头士。所以我坐在那里看演出，那家伙，女士们先生们，这就是披头士。这些家伙上台了，他们唱着这些翻唱歌曲。
And I'm looking at these guys. Shirts, ties, long hair and they're singing away and as a musician I'm going, God, there's something here. So I go backstage and I meet them and they're talking to me and oh, we love what you're doing. So they're saying, we want to do what
我看着这些家伙。衬衫、领带、长发，他们唱着歌，作为一个音乐家，我觉得，天哪，这里面有门道。所以我去后台见他们，他们跟我聊天，哦，我们喜欢你做的事。所以他们在说，我们想做你
you're doing. We want to publish and write and produce the music and blah, blah, blah and I strike it up with these Beatles. And then I go to London and I think they started with a hit and I'm having drinks with them over there and we're talking and rapping and I come home to New York where I'm living and I
正在做的事。我们想出版、写作和制作音乐，巴拉巴拉巴拉，我和这些披头士一拍即合。然后我去伦敦，我想他们凭借一首热门歌曲出道，我和他们在那里喝着酒，我们聊天，说唱，我回到我居住的纽约，我
go to Normie Weiss and Sid Bernstein, who are my agents. I said, there's these guys in England called the Beatles. You got to sign them. Now you have to remember, we're not in a media driven society. Pop music is still in its infancy stage. Nobody had any
去找诺米·维斯和西德·伯恩斯坦，他们是我的经纪人。我说，英国有这样几个叫披头士的家伙。你们得签下他们。现在你们必须记住，我们当时不在一个由媒体驱动的社会中。流行音乐还处于起步阶段。没有人有任何
idea what was going on in Europe. And I'm pounding these guys to go get them. Like Rock and Roll just started, right? Just started. Infancy stage. So long and short, they go over and they sign the Beatles and bring them over in what, 64 on Ed Sullivan? And that was the start of it
概念欧洲发生了什么。我一直催促这俩人去把他们签下来。就像摇滚乐刚开始一样，对吧？刚开始。起步阶段。长话短说，他们去了那边，签下了披头士，并在64年通过埃德·沙利文秀把他们带到了美国？这就是一切的
all. So they bring them over. You know the story there. I leave and I go to RCA Victor Records who built this huge sound stage in Rome and they introduce me to one of the most amazing genius musicians I've ever met called Inio
开始。所以他们把他们带过来了。你们知道那个故事。我离开后去了RCA维多利亚唱片公司，他们在罗马建立了一个巨大的录音棚，他们把我介绍给我见过的最了不起的天才音乐家之一，叫埃尼奥
Morricone. You guys must know that name. He knew films better than the directors and he was unbelievable. He starts my career in Italy and I'm singing and living in Italy. I'm out selling
莫里科内。你们一定知道这个名字。他比导演更懂电影，他太不可思议了。他在意大利开启了我的职业生涯，我在意大利唱歌并生活。我的唱片销量甚至
the Italians. Just in Italian. So I'm living there and I'm having a career in Italy with Inio Morricone. Who are you? The answer is probably yes. Throw it at me. I was going to say did you ever write a song for the Beatles?
超过了意大利人。所以我住在那里，和埃尼奥·莫里科内一起在意大利拥有了一番事业。你是谁？答案很可能是肯定的。抛给我吧。我本来想问你有没有为披头士写过歌？
No. They did their own thing. I wish I had. Do you know Italian? Yes. You could speak Italian. What other languages? I recorded in Spanish, recorded in Japanese. I lived in Germany and I had a career in
没有。他们做他们自己的事。我希望我有。你会说意大利语吗？会。你会说意大利语。还会其他语言吗？我在西班牙语、日语中录过音。我在德国住过，并且在德国拥有过
German in Germany. I get up in the morning at nine with this strict German woman, Siegret Folkman. You put it in your tongue in the front. I hadn't even had breakfast yet
德语的职业生涯。我早上九点和这个严厉的德国女人西格丽德·福尔克曼起床。你要把舌头放在前面。我甚至还没吃早饭
and I'm worried about my tongue and I sat with her five days a week learning German and I loved it over there. It's a great country. Beautiful. It's a great country, by the way. If you I want to know about
我就在担心我的舌头，我一周跟她坐五天学习德语，我很喜欢那里。那是个伟大的国家。美丽。顺便说一句，那是个伟大的国家。如果你 我想知道关于
I thought you were going to go back to embracing the bear in this theme room. I want to stick with the tongue. Love never felt so good that song. Michael Jackson. And then Justin Timberlake. We recorded it.
我以为你要回到蒸汽房里去拥抱那只熊。我想留在舌头上。《爱从未感觉如此美好》那首歌。迈克尔·杰克逊。然后是贾斯汀·汀布莱克。我们录制了它。
Drake and talk to us about the collaborations, the duets with some of these folks. Is that something you'd love to do? I started somewhere in there, I said I got to meet some other people and write with them because I love the experience.
德雷克，跟我们谈谈这些合作，与其中一些人的二重唱。那是你想做的事吗？我在某个地方开始时，我说我得去见见其他人并和他们一起写歌，因为我喜欢这种经历。
Anyway, I start with Michael McDonnell, Bert Backer, a bunch of talented people, good friends. This guy, publicist, kept bringing Michael Jackson around. I knew the family from Cezars. Joe would bring him in. They watched Sinatra and me, Dean Martin.
无论如何，我从迈克尔·麦克唐纳、伯特·巴卡拉开始，还有一帮有才华的人，好朋友。这家伙，公关，一直把迈克尔·杰克逊带在身边。我从凯撒宫时就认识这家人了。乔会把他带进来。他们看我和辛纳屈、迪恩·马丁演出。
And I saw this family grow up. We said Michael is starting over at Sony and he wants to write and be on your Sony album. And I had already had everybody slotted in the album and I had two slots open. And I'm living in Carmel at the time. And Michael flies up with this guy
我看着这个家庭长大。我们说迈克尔要在索尼重新开始，他想写歌并出现在你的索尼专辑里。我已经把专辑里的所有人都安排好了，我还剩两个空位。我当时住在卡梅尔。迈克尔和这个家伙一起飞了上来
and we start writing together. And you knew right away with a guy like Michael how talented he was. Now unlike everyone else he didn't play an instrument. He was all in the head. All these noises like working with a bird.
我们开始一起写歌。你立刻就能从像迈克尔这样的人身上看出他是多么有才华。现在与其他人不同的是，他不会乐器。全在脑子里。各种声音，就像跟一只鸟合作一样。
And I knew the way that this guy had it down. He knew what he wanted and he knew what he was about. So we sit. Paul, you sound just like him. Yeah, thank you very much. I do 20 minutes of that in my act every night. So we start writing in the middle of the process, which is
我知道这家伙把这一切都拿捏了。他知道他想要什么，他也知道他在做什么。所以我们坐着。保罗，你听起来真像他。是的，非常感谢。我每天在我的演出中做20分钟这个。所以我们开始写歌，在创作过程中，这
interesting. His record thriller, whatever the first one was, starts to take off. Michael goes into second gear of Michael, really into his career, really into being very professional. But he steals the tapes
很有趣。他的唱片《颤栗》，无论第一张是什么，开始腾飞。迈克尔进入了迈克尔的第二档，真正投入到他的职业生涯中，真正投入到变得非常专业中。但他把录音带从洛杉矶的录音室里
out of the studio in Los Angeles and I couldn't complete the songs with him because he had taken the tapes. Something happened to your face, Jason. I think you're growing an appendage. I grew a second face. Oh my god.
偷走了，我没能和他完成这些歌，因为他把录音带拿走了。你的脸出什么问题了，杰森。我觉得你长出了一个附属器官。我长了第二张脸。哦我的天呐。
You're a second elder. Oh my god. Here she comes. I'm just saying, I love you all. You're very tan. You look very cute. Amanda, wait, Amanda, don't go anywhere yet. I can't believe this is the first time meeting your dad. I love your dad.
你成了第二个长者。哦我的天呐。她来了。我只是想说，我爱你们所有人。你晒得很黑。你看起来很可爱。阿曼达，等等，阿曼达，先别走。我真不敢相信这是我第一次见你爸。我太喜欢你爸了。
I now know why you've been keeping him away. I can talk for hours. We love your dad. Sean didn't know about the tonight show. He came to a father-daughter dinner up at our Sundays and it took the house down. Yeah. He invited him back.
我现在知道你为什么一直把他藏着了。我可以聊几个小时。我们太喜欢你爸了。肖恩不知道《今夜秀》的事。他来参加我们周日的父女晚宴，把全场震撼了。是的。他邀请他回来。
Yes. He's a big hit. By the way, I love you all. Willie and Sean, I'm crushed that you're away. I know. We're going to see you very soon, but I miss you too. I'm so excited. Daddy, I miss you. I love you. I'll see you at the party, remember, next week.
是的。他是个大红人。顺便说一句，我爱你们所有人。威利和肖恩，你们不在我很难过。我知道。我们很快就会见到你，但我也想念你。我太兴奋了。爸爸，我想你。我爱你。下周聚会见，记得吗？
Yes, at your party. You're coming to dinner. I can't wait. I'm so excited. I love you guys. Bye. I love you too. Paul, will you be my dad? Michael Jackson took the tapes or something? He stole the tapes from the studio and they called me.
是的，在你的聚会上。你要来吃晚饭。我等不及了。我太兴奋了。爱你们，伙计们。拜拜。我也爱你们。保罗，你愿意当我爸爸吗？迈克尔·杰克逊拿走了录音带还是怎么的？他从录音室偷了录音带，他们打电话给我。
I hate being negative because he's a talented guy. In the 80s, Sunset Sound, they called me up and said, Michael came and took your tapes. Now, I've got the tapes are gone. I can't finish. But the tapes of what? Of songs that you were working on with him
我讨厌表现得消极，因为他是个有才华的人。80年代，日落之声，他们打电话给我说，迈克尔来把你的录音带拿走了。现在，录音带没了。我无法完成。但什么录音带？你和他一起创作的歌的录音带
or songs that you recorded? Three songs that we wrote together. Here's to give you the payoff in a second. The three songs. My tapes are gone and now I'm in Lawyerville and I'm not litigious. I think the worst thing you can do in life takes the eye off the ball is get into litigation
还是你录制的歌？我们一起写的三首歌。马上给你们揭晓结果。这三首歌。我的录音带没了，现在我在律师城，而我不是个好诉讼的人。我认为生活中最糟糕的事情就是把视线从球上移开，陷入诉讼中
if you can avoid it. Anyway, tapes are gone. I'll leave a hunk out. The lawyers decide to convince him, give him back the tapes. So he gives me back the tapes, but he's gone. I can't finish the project. Now, this is the 80s. The years go by
如果能避免的话。无论如何，录音带没了。我省略一段。律师们决定说服他，把录音带还给他。所以他把录音带还给我了，但他走了。我无法完成这个项目。现在，这是80年代。岁月流逝
and what happens when he comes back on the This Is It tour? I get a call from Harvey over TMZ. He said, Paul, there's a Michael Jackson record out called This Is It and we think you wrote it. And it's his tour.
当他带着《就是这样》巡演回来时发生了什么？我接到TMZ哈维的电话。他说，保罗，有一张迈克尔·杰克逊的唱片出来叫《就是这样》，我们觉得是你写的。那是他的巡演。
It's the name of the show. The documentary that you're shooting when he passed away. I said, Harvey, let me do some homework. So I get a hold of the record and what happened was the original title was called I Never Heard. This was called This Is It. When I hear the record,
那是演出名字。他去世时你正在拍摄的纪录片。我说，哈维，让我做点功课。所以我拿到了这张唱片，发生的事情是原来的歌名叫《我从未听过》。这个叫《就是这样》。当我听到这张唱片时，
the first line is This Is It Here I stand. They took the first lyric, turned it into the tour title, and indeed it was the song that we wrote together. Well, now this shit hits the fans.
第一句是“就是这样，我站在这里”。他们拿了第一句歌词，把它变成了巡演的名字，而这确实是我们一起写的歌。好吧，现在这破事捅到马蜂窝了。
This is only like in the 2000s. It wasn't that long ago. Yeah, exactly. So now we get the same lawyers on the phone again. Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba What are you doing? That's our song, did you? Oh, you know, lawyers. Oh, we didn't know, Bob.
这大概是2000年代的事了。离现在没多久。对，没错。所以现在我们又把同样的律师叫到电话前。巴巴巴巴巴你们在干什么？那是我们的歌，是不是？哦，你知道的，律师。哦，我们不知道，鲍勃。
I said, look, let's make it real simple. You're stuck. Your tour is named. You got a record coming out in a week. We'll make this very sweet. I want half of everything or you're not going to put it out. Well, we got everything. So then after This Is It came out,
我说，听着，我们把它搞得简单点。你们卡壳了。你们的巡演名字定下来了。你们一周后就要发片了。我们把这事弄得很甜蜜。我要一切的一半，否则你们别想发行。好吧，我们拿到了全部。然后《就是这样》出来后，
I got a call from the guy that was running Epic Records, L.A. Reed. I said, did you write a song called Love Number Felt So Good With Michael? I said, yes, he says, well, it's coming out with Timberlake and Michael. I said, what did you do?
我接到管理史诗唱片公司的家伙L·A·里德的电话。我说，你是不是和迈克尔写过一首歌叫《爱从未感觉如此美好》？我说，是的，他说，嗯，这首歌要由汀布莱克和迈克尔一起发行了。我说，你们干了什么？
He says, we found these tapes in his drawer. We thought they were his and we made a record out of it. I said, well, it's going to be half of it. Let me give you an address. Thanks for doing the heavy lifting. That song is fantastic. It's such a good song.
他说，我们在他的抽屉里发现了这些录音带。我们以为是他的，就做成了一张唱片。我说，好吧，这得对半分。我给你个地址。谢谢你们做重体力活。那首歌太棒了。真的是首好歌。
So it comes out. There's that. I got a call, Drake. Did you write a song? Yes. So he comes over the house. Nice guy, talented Toronto boy, as you know. Yeah, Toronto guy. And he said, look, what do we do with this? I said, look, I don't know anything about your world.
所以它发行了。就是这样。我接到电话，德雷克。你写过一首歌吗？是的。所以他来到我家。人很好，是个有才华的多伦多男孩，如你所知。对，多伦多男孩。他说，听着，我们怎么处理这个？我说，听着，我对你的世界一无所知。
Culturally, I can't write what you do. But if you want to take this and break the code and put your magic on it, let me hear it. You can put it out. He takes it. What I'd written and what was there with Michael and he turned it into something that doesn't matter to me.
从文化上讲，我写不出你做的那种东西。但如果你想拿着这个，破解密码并施展你的魔法，让我听听。你可以把它发行。他拿走了。我写的东西和迈克尔在那里的东西，他把它变成了一些对我来说无关紧要的东西。
And that was the third record. Wow. That's unbelievable. Crazy stories, huh? Incredible. We'll be right back. The secret sauce is that they're the first company to sell wireless service online only.
那是第三张唱片。哇。这太不可思议了。疯狂的故事，对吧？难以置信。我们马上回来。秘诀在于他们是第一家仅在线销售无线服务的公司。
They cut out the cost of retail stores and pass those sweet savings directly to you. For anyone who hates their phone bill, anybody with skin and a body, Mint Mobile offers premium wireless for just 15 bucks a month.
他们砍掉了零售店的成本，并将这些丰厚的省下来的钱直接转让给你。对于任何痛恨手机账单的人，任何有皮有肉的人，薄荷移动提供优质无线服务，每月只需15美元。
Mint Mobile gives you the best rate whether you're buying for one or a family. And that Mint family started with five G mains. All plans come with unlimited talk and text plus high speed data delivered on the nation's largest 5G network. Use your own phone with any Mint Mobile
无论你是为一个人还是一个家庭购买，薄荷移动都能给你提供最优惠的价格。而这个薄荷家庭是从五个G网开始的。所有套餐都附带无限通话和短信，外加在全美最大的5G网络上提供的高速数据。在任何薄荷移动套餐中
plan and keep your same phone number along with all your existing contacts. To this day, I don't know with 5G mains. But I know it's better than 4G. Use your own phone with any Mint Mobile plan and keep your same phone number along with all your existing contacts. Switch to Mint Mobile and get premium
使用你自己的手机，保留你现有的电话号码以及你所有的现有联系人。直到今天，我也不知道5G网是怎么回事。但我知道它比4G好。在任何薄荷移动套餐中使用你自己的手机，保留你现有的电话号码以及你所有的现有联系人。切换到薄荷移动，获得优质
wireless service starting at just 15 bucks a month. To get your new wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month and get the plan shipped to your door for free, go to mintmobile.com slash smartlist. That's mintmobile.com slash smartlist.
无线服务，起价仅需每月15美元。要以每月仅15美元的价格获取你的新无线套餐，并免费将套餐运送到你的门前，请访问mintmobile.com斜杠smartlist。那是mintmobile.com斜杠smartlist。
Cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at mintmobile.com slash smartlist. Today, we're working and communicating more quickly than ever. And sometimes we can feel stuck. Give yourself a helping hand with Grammarly Go. Grammarly Go understands your
在mintmobile.com斜杠smartlist上将你的无线账单削减至每月15美元。今天，我们工作和交流的速度比以往任何时候都快。有时我们会感到卡壳。使用Grammarly Go给自己伸出援手。Grammarly Go了解你的
unique context, preferred voice and goals to quickly generate high quality writing. With just a few clicks you can ideate, compose, rewrite and reply thoughtfully. Struggling with new ideas, input a prompt and Grammarly Go will generate innovative suggestions to help you move your ideas
独特语境、首选语调和目标，以快速生成高质量的写作。只需点击几下，你就可以构思、创作、重写并深思熟虑地回复。还在为新点子苦恼吗？输入提示，Grammarly Go将生成创新建议，帮助你推进你的想法
forward. So for me, a few weeks ago I got emergency laser surgery on one of my eyes and I couldn't read or write. So all I could do was dictate or speak into it. So what Grammarly Go did for me was help me kind of outline a speech that I had to give and then Scotty filled in the rest and it came out
向前发展。所以对几周前的我来说，我的一只眼睛做了紧急激光手术，我无法阅读或写作。所以我能做的就是口述或向它讲话。所以Grammarly Go为我做的是帮我勾勒出我要发表的演讲的大纲，然后斯科蒂填补了其余部分，结果非常
terrific. Because Scotty is also based on AI. He's generated he's not even real. Scott-E is his name. You'll be amazed at what you can do with Grammarly Go. Go to Grammarly.com slash go to download and learn more about Grammarly Go. That's
棒。因为斯科蒂也是基于人工智能的。他是生成的，他甚至不是真实的。他的名字叫斯科蒂。你会对用Grammarly Go能做的事感到惊讶。访问Grammarly.com斜杠go下载并了解更多关于Grammarly Go的信息。那是
g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y dot com slash go. SmartList is supported by Rocket Money. Have you ever rediscovered a subscription you forgot about and had been paying for months? I did like years and years ago. Remember that 90s internet
g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y点com斜杠go。SmartList由Rocket Money赞助。你是否曾重新发现一个你忘记了并且已经支付了数月的订阅？我几年前就这样做过。还记得那个90年代的网络
service company? I won't say who it is. I had it forever and I kept paying for it and I had to discover it on my own. I don't remember how I discovered it. I was just like wait am I still paying for that? And I've been paying for it for years. I don't know how much money I lost on that thing.
服务公司吗？我不会说是谁。我拥有它很久了，我一直在付钱，我不得不自己发现它。我不记得我是怎么发现的。我只是想，等等，我还在为那个付钱吗？我已经为它付了好几年钱了。我不知道我在那东西上损失了多少钱。
Do you know how much your subscriptions really cost? Most Americans think they spend around $80 a month on subscriptions. But the actual total is closer to $200. If you don't know exactly how much you're spending every month, you need Rocket Money. Rocket Money is a personal finance app that finds and cancels
你知道你的订阅实际上花你多少钱吗？大多数美国人认为他们每月在订阅上花费大约80美元。但实际总额接近200美元。如果你不知道你每个月确切花多少钱，你需要Rocket Money。Rocket Money是一款个人理财应用，可以查找并取消
your unwanted subscriptions, monitors your spending, and helps you lower your bills all in one place. Over 80% of people have subscriptions they forgot about and chances are you're one of them. Like that one streaming app just to watch one show or that free gaming trial you never actually use.
你不需要的订阅，监控你的支出，并帮助你在一个地方降低账单。超过80%的人都有他们忘记的订阅，而你很有可能是其中之一。就像为了看一部剧而订的那个流媒体应用，或者你从不真正使用的那个免费游戏试玩。
Rocket Money will quickly and easily find your subscriptions for you and for any you don't want to pay for anymore. Just hit cancel and Rocket Money will cancel it for you. It's that easy. Rocket Money also helps you manage all your finances in one place and automatically categorizes your expenses. So you can
Rocket Money将为你快速轻松地找到你的订阅，对于任何你不想再付费的订阅。只需点击取消，Rocket Money就会为你取消。就是这么简单。Rocket Money还帮你在一个地方管理你所有的财务，并自动对你的支出进行分类。所以你可以
easily track your budget in real time and also get alerted if anything looks off. Over 3 million people have used Rocket Money saving the average person up to $720 a year. Stop throwing your money away. Cancel unwanted subscriptions and manage your expenses. The easy way
轻松实时追踪你的预算，如果有什么看起来不对劲也会得到警报。超过300万人使用过Rocket Money，平均每年为每个人节省高达720美元。别再把钱扔掉了。取消不需要的订阅并管理你的支出。通过访问
by going to RocketMoney.com slash SmartLess. That's RocketMoney.com slash SmartLess. RocketMoney.com slash SmartLess. And now, back to the show. So, you know, I put your head on my shoulder. I mean, pop you love. You're having my baby.
RocketMoney.com斜杠SmartLess以简单的方式做到这一点。那是RocketMoney.com斜杠SmartLess。RocketMoney.com斜杠SmartLess。现在，回到节目中。所以，你知道的，我把你的头放在我的肩膀上。我是说，大众所爱。你要生我的孩子了。
My way, all this stuff. Every time I think about all the really recognizable songs that you have that you have done. I keep thinking about it. I'm going to ask you about this again. And I would like your take on it, guys. I want him to remember the three tenors.
《我的方式》，所有这些东西。每当我想到你创作的所有那些真正具有极高辨识度的歌曲。我一直在思考这件事。我一会儿还要问你这个。我想听听你们的看法，伙计们。我想让他记住三大男高音。
Remember the three tenors. Remember the three tenors. I want him to do the three crooners because each you can, you got it. Let's workshop and find the other two folks. But you've got enough you've got enough to fill
记住三大男高音。记住三大男高音。我想让他做三大克鲁纳歌手，因为每个人你都可以，你懂的。让我们头脑风暴并找出另外两个家伙。但你已经足够了，你已经足够填补
your section of it. I mean, in spades. I mean, you're playing your hits. You could do you could tour it. You could do Vegas. As you know, you could do on Broadway. It would be an absolute smash. Yeah. Who's who are the other two that would do it with you? That's a big question.
你的部分。我是说，完全如此。我是说，你在唱你的成名曲。你可以去巡演。你可以去拉斯维加斯。如你所知，你可以去百老汇。那绝对会大获成功。是啊。还有另外两个人是谁，会和你一起做这件事？这是一个大问题。
Who are the other twos that leave their ego at the door? You tell us. You know these guys. You know these players. Well, you know, Paul, you just said something really important before you answered that, which is check your ego. And I love hearing you talk because you have been around and seen it all. And I can tell that you don't have time for the
哪另外两个人能把自我意识抛在一边？你告诉我们。你了解这些人。你了解这些玩家。嗯，你知道，保罗，你在回答之前刚刚说了一件非常重要的事情，那就是克制自我。我喜欢听你说话，因为你见多识广，经历过这一切。我看得出来，你没时间去理会那些
bullshit. You don't have that ego in that way. I love that there's an authenticity to it that is so refreshing because we don't have enough. And by the way, I was thinking you're talking about the mob before. I mean, you're in the talent mafia. You have been doing it and you have been working with and collaborating
废话。你没有那种自负。我喜欢那种非常清爽的真实感，因为我们现在很缺乏这种东西。顺便说一句，我刚才还在想你之前说的黑手党。我是说，你在人才黑手党里。你一直在做这个，你和人们合作
with people for so freaking long. There's no reason you can't do this now. It would be a crime if you didn't do it. Well, if you've got time. I mean, you're doing your Broadway show. You're working on the documentary. You're probably writing another book and you're touring. Well, I'm touring. I leave for Asia in May.
合作了这么久。你现在没有理由不这么做。如果你不这么做，那将是一种罪过。好吧，如果你有时间的话。我是说，你在做你的百老汇演出。你在制作纪录片。你可能还在写另一本书，而且你在巡演。好吧，我在巡演。我五月份要去亚洲。
We're booked right up until next January. You know, the problem is this. You have to have a business mind and an artistic mind in this business. You really do. You've got to watch your stuff. And every time I've addressed it, you've got managers in the way. You've got agents in the way and you've got
我们的演出预订一直排到明年一月。你知道，问题在于这个。在这个行业里，你必须既有商业头脑，又有艺术头脑。真的必须如此。你得看好你的东西。而且每次我解决这个问题时，都会有经纪人挡道。会有代理人挡道，而且还会有
some artists who are very talented. But that's it. There's no business acumen and there's threats. They don't want to get on stage with certain performers. They don't want to go through it. They don't get it. And it's a shame. You know who gets it? The country acts get it.
一些很有才华的艺术家。但仅此而已。没有商业头脑，而且还有威胁。他们不想和某些表演者同台。他们不想经历这些。他们不明白。这太遗憾了。你知道谁明白吗？乡村歌手明白。
The rap artists get it. But there's not many in my milieu that I could really say to you, look, I'd love to bring Julio Iglesias out of retirement or whatever he's doing, okay? Because the Hispanic base in our country
说唱歌手明白。但在我的圈子里，没有多少人我能对你直说，听着，我很想让胡里奥·伊格莱西亚斯复出或者管他正在做什么，好吧？因为在我们国家，西班牙裔的基数
politically and everything is huge. Yeah. If you could get Tom Jones, Tom has been, you know, had some health issues recently, great voice. There's a few people that I think would work, but you can't get past the agents, the managers. Well,
在政治和各方面都非常庞大。是的。如果你能请到汤姆·琼斯，汤姆最近你知道的，有一些健康问题，嗓音很棒。我觉得有几个人选可行，但你绕不过经纪人和经理人。好吧，
somebody would have to do it. I just don't have any time to press it. Great. It's a smart list tour and we're going to get it done. Guys, why don't the three of us sing all the songs? I'm open. Songs are not responsible for any of the songs. Sean, you do the singing
总得有人去干这事。我只是没时间去推进它。太棒了。这是一个精明名单巡演，我们要把它办成。伙计们，为什么我们三个不把所有的歌都唱了？我持开放态度。歌曲不负责任何歌曲。肖恩，你负责唱歌
and then Jason and I, what do we do? Well, these two talented guys would always do that. We'll make funny faces on the sides. You put me on your shoulders. Oh my god. I mean, just, well, we're going to work on it. We're going to come back to you with a proposal on that. Okay.
然后杰森和我，我们做什么？嗯，这两个有才华的人总是会做那个。我们在旁边做鬼脸。你把我扛在肩上。哦，天哪。我是说，总之，我们要努力。我们会带着关于这个的提案回来找你的。好吧。
It's a great idea. Now talk to us about this, you know, the stamina, the endurance, the longevity, you still touring like crazy. Literally, how do you do that?
这是个好主意。现在跟我们聊聊这个，你知道的，体力、耐力、长寿，你仍然在疯狂地巡演。字面意义上，你是怎么做到的？
Yeah, but how are you able to stay so healthy and have someone say, what's the ritual? Yeah, look, walk us through your day. It's so basic. Look, you know, I know what you do. You run, you watch what you eat. You know, Amanda's always been like
是啊，但你是怎么保持这么健康，让别人问，秘诀是什么？是的，听着，给我们讲讲你的一天。太基础了。看，你知道的，我知道你做什么。你跑步，你注意饮食。你知道，阿曼达一直都是
that. I literally from hanging around those guys in Vegas with the smoking with the drinking and all the bullshit. Hey, if that's your thing, do it. I couldn't sing if I drank too much. Right. I couldn't function if I did what too much.
那样。我字面意义上，从跟拉斯维加斯那些家伙混在一起抽烟喝酒和那些废话开始。嘿，如果那是你的爱好，那就去做吧。如果我喝太多酒，我就唱不出歌。对。如果我做什么做得太多，我就无法正常运作。
I tried a little of this and that you got damn right. You made up my mind and made choices. But when I get up in the morning, you know, I have my lemon juice. I eat blueberries. I have my olive oil with a squeeze of lemon. I don't have a big breakfast. I don't eat white bread. I can give you
我尝试过一点这个那个，你说得对。你让我下定决心并做出了选择。但当我早晨起床时，你知道的，我喝柠檬汁。我吃蓝莓。我吃橄榄油加几滴柠檬汁。我不吃丰盛的早餐。我不吃白面包。我可以给你
a boring list. This body is not a fluke. Okay. This is it. Even Paul Acke is quoting Richard Erlich. Is that Richard Erlich? Was that where I heard it? Great Richard. How's Richard doing? Tricky Dick.
列出一份无聊的清单。这具身体绝不是侥幸。好吧。就是这样。甚至连保罗·阿克都在引用理查德·埃利希的话。那是理查德·埃利希吗？是在那里听到的吗？伟大的理查德。理查德最近怎么样？狡猾的迪克。
He's married, isn't he? Oh, yeah. Tell Tracy who Richard is. Richard is one of my best friends and a friend of what, all four of us? No. And anyway,
他结婚了，对吧？哦，是的。告诉特雷西理查德是谁。理查德是我最好的朋友之一，也是我们四个中谁的朋友？不是。不管怎样，
Richard is, I love, by the way it should be noticed, yeah, hi, Dick. It should be mentioned that Richard is one of the first smart list super fans when we first met. He was like the first guy to keep texting us and being encouraging. He's such a
理查德是，顺便说一句，应该注意到，是的，嗨，迪克。应该提到的是，理查德是我们刚认识时最早的聪明名单超级粉丝之一。他就像第一个不断给我们发短信并给予鼓励的人。他真是个
sweet heart. You want to buy a house? By the way, you want to buy a house now? I get Richard Erlich. He's eating blueberries right now. That's how he's getting through this interview. This is a super food. I love it. I'm going to do it now, Paul. I'm doing it every day.
大甜心。你想买栋房子吗？顺便问一下，你现在想买栋房子吗？我明白了理查德·埃利希。他现在正在吃蓝莓。这就是他熬过这次采访的方式。这是超级食物。我喜欢。我现在就要这么做，保罗。我每天都在做。
You put it in a shot glass and you squeeze a lemon on top of it and drink it. Before you go to bed you make sure you have ginger. I'd rather drink a soda and die early. Listen, Sean, you're not going to make it to Paul's age. You keep having the corn flakes on the tuna fish.
你把它放进一个小酒杯里，上面挤一点柠檬汁然后喝下去。在你睡觉前，确保你吃了生姜。我宁愿喝苏打水然后早点死。听着，肖恩，你活不到保罗那个年纪。你一直吃玉米片配金枪鱼。
Listen, they're coming up with some stuff from Israel. I read a lot. They've got some stuff now. They're going to turn it out a lot back. You're going to live to over 100 years old. Especially kids that were born after 2000. They'll be living to 125.
听着，他们正在从以色列弄一些东西。我读了很多书。他们现在有一些东西。他们会把它大量推出来。你能活到100岁以上。特别是2000年后出生的小孩。他们能活到125岁。
Now, what about playing music day to day? Not physically playing music because you're doing that on the stage. What are you listening to that's keeping you inspired? Do you keep up on new music?
现在，关于日常演奏音乐呢？不是在物理层面上演奏音乐，因为你在舞台上做那个。你都在听什么来保持灵感？你会关注新音乐吗？
Do you have a staple that you listen to that keeps you going? What gets you going? I'm listening to everything eclectically. There's some stuff I'm not interested in. Believe it or not. But I'm listening to stuff from Adele, some rap stuff,
你有什么经常听的曲目能让你坚持下去吗？是什么让你充满动力？我什么都听，兼容并蓄。有些东西我没兴趣。信不信由你。但我听阿黛尔的歌，一些说唱音乐，
Jay-Z. There's some talented people out there. Is there anybody that you've always dreamed of writing for or with? Elton John and Sting. Wow. I think Elton's very talented. I think Sting is very talented. I think Billy Joel is amazing.
Jay-Z。外面有一些很有才华的人。有没有谁是你一直梦想着为之写歌或合作的？埃尔顿·约翰和斯汀。哇。我觉得埃尔顿很有才华。我觉得斯汀很有才华。我觉得比利·乔尔太棒了。
You're never going to discount. When you look at the foundation of those doing the business out there, it's all the guys that are close to 80. Stones are still doing it. There's a ton of them. There's some good stuff out there that I listen to opera music
你永远不会忽视。当你看到那些在外面做生意的人的基础时，都是那些快80岁的人。滚石乐队还在坚持。有海量这样的人。外面有一些好东西，当我想要冷静下来时，我会听歌剧音乐
when I want to calm down. I listen to a lot of Sinatra. I listen to everything as long as it's good. If it's good, I'm on. I'm down for it. Paul, for many, many reasons, I want to be you when I grow up. We never grow up, my boy.
。我听很多弗兰克·辛纳屈的歌。只要好听，我都听。只要好听，我都行。我完全赞成。保罗，出于许多许多原因，当我长大后，我想成为你。我们从不长大，我的孩子。
We never really grow up. I get that sense. Paul, it's unbelievable. I don't know what Jason, I think he's jealous of you. You've got too much charisma for us. He knows that we're like,
我们从未真正长大。我有这种感觉。保罗，这太不可思议了。我不知道杰森怎么想，我觉得他嫉妒你。你的个人魅力对我们来说太强了。他知道我们就像是，
Sean and I are going to be like, we've got to get rid of Jason. We've got to get Paul to do the podcast with us. We'll keep it in the family. If you guys want to recast, that's fine. You've got to keep it in the family. I've got to tell you, I'm so proud of that guy. I don't know how to lay it on.
肖恩和我将要觉得，我们得甩掉杰森。我们得让保罗和我们一起做播客。我们要把肥水留在自家田里。如果你们想重新选角，那没问题。你们得把肥水留在自家田里。我得告诉你，我为那家伙感到骄傲。我不知道该怎么表达，
All of you representing what you do, I'm not going to lie in front of me and he's been a hell of a father with those kids, but beyond that, I'm not even going to get into it because it speaks for itself, and I'm not going to embarrass him. But as proud as he may be of me,
你们所有人代表着你们所做的事，我不会当着我的面说谎，而且他一直是个了不起的父亲，对那些孩子很好，但除此之外，我甚至不想深入谈论它，因为它不言自明，我也不想让他难堪。但无论他可能为我感到多么骄傲，
that's how proud is Jason, is he, is that your son-in-law? Everywhere I go, they don't even know who the fuck I am. We're taking these guests, right? But they... Listen, whatever you're throwing at me, I'm throwing it back to all of you. I'm throwing that up, which was...
杰森也为我感到同样骄傲，他是吗，那是你女婿吗？我无论去到哪里，他们甚至都不知道我他妈是谁。我们在带这些嘉宾，对吧？但他们……听着，不管你扔给我什么，我都把它扔回给你们所有人。我把它抛向空中，那是……
I wanted to mention this earlier. When Amanda started dating, when he said that he didn't know, that he figured that you were Amanda's dad when he first heard her last name, when Jason and Amanda got started dating and then got married, and I don't want to embarrass Jason either
我之前就想提这个。当阿曼达开始约会时，当他说他不知道，当他第一次听到她的姓氏时，他以为你是阿曼达的爸爸，当杰森和阿曼达开始约会然后结婚时，我也不想让杰森难堪
because Sean and I both love him. I give him a lot of shit, but I love him and he's a brother and more than a friend. How lucky did you feel that you got to have this guy as your son-in-law and in your life? He's a thoughtful, smart, sweet, great dad.
因为肖恩和我都很爱他。我经常损他，但我爱他，他就像兄弟，甚至超越了朋友。你觉得自己有多幸运，能让这家伙成为你的女婿并走进你的生活？他是一个体贴、聪明、温柔、棒极了的爸爸。
All this shit that you said times a million as you know. No doubt. He's a brother from another mother to all of you guys because you know the great thing is, as you guys know, it's all real. You're never going to hear anybody say anything
你说的所有这些破事乘以一百万，正如你所知。毫无疑问。他是你们所有人的异父异母的兄弟，因为你们知道最棒的事是，正如你们所知，这一切都是真的。你永远不会听到任何人说任何
and I never have. And Jason's been through it, man. You'll never hear anybody say anything derogatory about Jason. It's true. You had a nice little window into it. We're still looking though. I'll find it.
而且我从来没有听过。而且杰森经历过风雨，老兄。你永远不会听到任何人说关于杰森的任何诋毁之词。千真万确。你对它有过一个小小的窗口了解。不过我们仍在寻找。我会找到的。
Paul had a nice window into my old life though. Right when I got married to his daughter, he took me and two buddies, Erlich was one of them, Dickey, to Vegas and he gave me and Richard and Danny Comden and
不过保罗对我的旧生活有一个很好的了解窗口。就在我和他女儿结婚后，他带着我和两个哥们，埃利希是其中之一，迪基，去了拉斯维加斯，他把我和理查德、丹尼·康登还有
the whole solid crew. He showed us his version of Vegas and it was just incredible. And so you got to see me lubricated, you know.
整个铁杆团队。他向我们展示了他的拉斯维加斯版本，简直太棒了。所以你看到了喝了酒的我，你知道的。
Erlich was making deals right down to the end. What do you mean $30 for a lap dance? Who's gonna kick over here? I'm not paying that. No, he wasn't. Jimmy's listening to this right now going, Richard said he's never been to a strip bar before.
埃利希一直把交易谈到最后一刻。什么意思，膝上舞要30美元？谁要在这里买单？我才不付这个钱。不，他才不呢。吉米听到这儿会说，理查德说他以前从没去过脱衣舞俱乐部。
This is crazy. Paul, we've taken a lot of your time, too much of it. You're very, very nice to have come on and done this. Thank you for saying yes. Paul, next time I'm in Los Angeles, I want to have a dinner and keep talking about everything
这太疯狂了。保罗，我们占用了你很多时间，太多了。你非常非常好，能来参加并完成这个。谢谢你答应。保罗，下次我在洛杉矶时，我想吃个晚饭，继续聊聊你生活中的
in your life. Let's do a dinner. Paul, please, what a thrill. We're doing that as soon as you get back. My mom and dad, my dad who grew up in Winnipeg, Manitoba has been a fan of yours. He was born in 38 just outside of Winnipeg. For him,
一切。我们吃个晚饭吧。保罗，拜托，这太让人激动了。你一回来我们就安排。我的爸爸妈妈，我那个在曼尼托巴省温尼伯长大的爸爸一直是你的粉丝。他38年出生在温尼伯郊外。对他来说，
I'm not kidding. As soon as I'm done, I'm going to get off this thing and I'm going to call my dad and say that we had you on and he's going to be absolutely blown away. He's going to be blown away. You've got a pretty decent hockey team out there. Yeah, we do. That's what we should do. We should go to a hockey game together.
我不是开玩笑。我一结束，我就要挂断这个电话，然后给我的爸爸打电话，告诉他我们请到了你，他绝对会被惊艳到的。他会被惊艳到的。你们那里有一支相当不错的冰球队。是的，我们有。我们应该这么做。我们应该一起去看一场冰球比赛。
We should introduce him to Shani, too. We should. Do you know which team in the NHL makes more money than any other team? You guys are hockey savvy. Toronto? Let me see. Toronto Maple Leafs. Everybody is way behind.
我们也应该把他介绍给沙尼。我们应该。你知道NHL里哪支球队赚的钱比其他任何球队都多吗？你们对冰球很精通。多伦多？让我想想。多伦多枫叶队。其他所有人都远远落后。
Do you know why Wayne Gretzky never had a curved stick? Why? Why is that? Because he always scored on his backhand. He never wanted the stick curved. Hardest tradition. I knew Wayne when he was a young little fella. He used to fly him around on the jet.
你知道为什么韦恩·格雷茨基从来不用弯曲的球杆吗？为什么？为什么会这样？因为他总是在反手射门。他从来不想让球杆弯曲。最难的传统。我年轻时就认识韦恩这个小家伙。我以前用喷气机载着他四处飞。
So I knew him when. So, you know, Paul, I don't know if you heard the episode that we did with President Biden, but what he wanted to do and did do, he was so excited because I guess he did all some research, found out that you and I were related.
所以我那时就认识他。所以，你知道，保罗，我不知道你是否听过我们采访拜登总统的那集，他想做而且确实做了的是，他非常兴奋，因为我猜他做了一些研究，发现你和我其实有亲戚关系。
He came in playing one of your songs on his phone. It's one of his go-to songs that he's got on his phone all the time. It played his interest music. On his own personal cell phone. I thought you were putting me on. Nobody handed it to him.
他一边用手机播放着你的一首歌一边走进来。这是他手机里随时都有的保留曲目之一。他播放了作为出场音乐的歌。在他的个人手机上。我还以为你在开玩笑呢。没人递给他。
He got it on his own phone. He walks in playing that. Jason blushed. And then I feel like, did we call you? Yeah, we called. He called me. I said, I'm only doing this with your son because I said I wanted to talk to you.
他是用他自己的手机放的。他走进来放着那个。杰森脸红了。然后我觉得，我们给你打电话了吗？对，我们打了。他打给我。我说，我只跟你的儿子做这个，因为我说我想和你谈谈。
I was getting ready from the world I come from to say, fuck you, Jason. Don't put me on. And then I heard the sound of his voice is real. And then he carried on as you heard him. He was very complimentary and very nice. I was very touched and it was very cool.
我从我出身的世界里准备好说，操你的，杰森。别把我扯进去。然后我听到他的声音是真的。接着正如你所听到的那样，他继续说下去。他非常赞赏，也非常客气。我很感动，而且非常酷。
It's cool for us to experience all of that happening in front of our face. Very, very cool. Paul, you've been killing it for a long, long time and many, many years to come. We can only hope to have the kind of longevity and relevance that you've had in this business
能亲眼目睹这一切发生，对我们来说太酷了。非常非常酷。保罗，你一直牛了很长很长的时间，而且还会有很多很多年。我们只能希望在这个行业里能有你那样的长寿和影响力，
and your success and your personal life too. I mean, I'm a huge benefit of your offspring as well. And we got a couple of great grandkids of yours to prove it. So I just love you and thanks for chatting with us.
还有你的成功以及你的个人生活。我是说，我也是你后代的巨大受益者。我们有几个你伟大的孙辈来证明这一点。所以我只是爱着你，谢谢你和我们聊天。
Hey guys, it's been my pleasure. My pleasure. Thank you. Thank you, Paul. Paul, thank you. The great Paul. I look forward to the dinner, guys. That's a done deal. Let me know when you're back. All right. All right.
嘿，伙计们，这是我的荣幸。我的荣幸。谢谢你们。谢谢你，保罗。保罗，谢谢你。伟大的保罗。我期待着晚餐，伙计们。一言为定。等你回来告诉我。好的。好的。
See you, Paulie. Bye, guys. Bye, buddy. Bye. What a legend. I mean, I can't believe you guys haven't met him before. I'm not kidding. I'm not kidding either. We haven't met him yet.
再见，保利。再见，伙计们。再见，兄弟。再见。真是个传奇。我是说，我真不敢相信你们之前没见过他。我不是开玩笑。我也不是开玩笑。我们还没见过他呢。
You're like, oh yeah, he's great. I love him. He's great. I can't believe you haven't paraded him and being like, Sean and Will, I love this guy. I wasn't even sure that you guys were going to be cool with me bringing him on. Yes, why not?
你们就像是，哦对，他很好。我爱他。他很好。我真不敢相信你们没有把他拉出来游街并说，肖恩和威尔，我爱这家伙。我甚至不确定你们是否会同意我把他请来。是的，为什么不呢？
Because it's just so self-serving. He's my father-in-law and I want to bring him on and chat with him. Do you ever call him Panka? No, but that can be your little pet name for him. No, you guys were very, very sweet to him.
因为这太自私了。他是我的岳父，我想把他请来和他聊天。你叫过他潘卡吗？没有，但这可以成为你对他的小昵称。不，你们对他非常非常温柔。
I'm dead serious. I want to sit down with him. I'm not even kidding. He'll talk to you every day. I was going to ask him if he's ever whacked anybody. That's a great question. I know that Sean has,
我是认真的。我想和他坐下来聊聊。我甚至不是在开玩笑。他会每天都跟你聊天的。我本来想问他是否曾做掉过任何人。这是个好问题。我知道肖恩做过，
but that's different. That was mutual. Oh my God. Sean got led into the mob because the first thing he said he said I love whacking people. Well, you're in. Just sign here.
但那是另一回事。那是双向奔赴。哦天哪。肖恩被引入黑手党是因为他说的第一句话是，我喜欢做掉别人。好吧，你入伙了。在这儿签字就行。
Okay. That same app that your friend used to say. The same app. Howdy. That's amazing. By the way, go ahead and win what we're going to say. No, I was just going to say, I'm really blown away, Jay. I really am.
好的。你朋友用来讲的那个同款应用。同款应用。哈啰。太惊人了。顺便说一句，接着说我们要说的话。不，我只是想说，杰，我真的被震撼到了。我真的是。
I just love him. And loving Amanda as much as we do as well, certainly as much as I do. Just seeing her dad and starting to understand, putting the pieces together. I got met one of Amanda's sisters. I remember I played golf with Amanda's mom. You and I played golf with her mom years ago
我只是爱他。而且我们对阿曼达的爱同样深厚，当然和我对她的一样。仅仅看到她的爸爸并开始理解，把拼图拼凑在一起。我见过阿曼达的一个姐妹。我记得我和阿曼达的妈妈打过高尔夫球。你和我几年前和她妈妈打过高尔夫球
before she passed, which was such a treat. Yeah. And then just meeting her dad now which just brought it all full circle and it just makes me love Amanda even more. Yeah, likewise. With that name that she came on and said hi, I was the first time on the show.
在她去世之前，那真是一种享受。是的。然后现在见到她的爸爸，这让一切都圆满了，这让我更爱阿曼达了。是的，彼此彼此。带着那个她打招呼的名字，那是我在节目中的第一次。
She's never done that. It was so cute. We should have her on. No, because we want to hear the real stuff. Yeah. I don't think I can be on that episode. No, because she'll get too real. She'll be like, I told Jason, I told him.
她从没那样做过。太可爱了。我们应该请她来。不，因为我们要听真实的。是的。我觉得我不能参加那一集。不，因为她会太真实。她会说，我告诉过杰森，我告诉过他。
Jay, I want to start fighting. It'll be a one hour fight. I didn't want to stay silent during that. I want to echo what Paul and Will are saying too, but what an incredible father you are, what an incredible person you are. Truly. And this is the episode to say that
杰，我想开始吵架了。那将是一场一个小时的争吵。我不想在那个时候保持沉默。我也想呼应保罗和威尔所说的话，但你是一个多么了不起的父亲，你是一个多么了不起的人。真的。这就是要说那一集
and this is the time to say that. Love on you is really cool. Very nice. I feel like you're working into a bye here. I am. I wanted to quote some of the lyrics from my way that I didn't know he wrote until today. I can't say I did it by way.
这也是说这话的时候。爱你真的很酷。非常棒。我觉得你在往退场铺垫呢。我是。我想引用《走我自己的路》里的几句歌词，我直到今天才知道是他写的。我不能说我是用我的方式做到的。
Why not. We can't say that because that's not a fucking thing. Yes, it is. You fucking blew it. Anybody who heard you say that knew exactly what you mean. He's going to talk about sleeping with a man and a woman all these lyrics. Right?
为什么不。我们不能那么说，因为那根本不是什么狗屁东西。是的，就是。你他妈搞砸了。任何听到你这么说的人都知道你的意思。他要谈论和男人女人睡觉的所有歌词。对吧？
Go ahead, John. I was going to do just the one lyric about, I planned each charted course, each careful step along the, bye! Bye! Way! Way! Way! Very nice.
说吧，约翰。我只想唱一句歌词，关于，我规划了每个图解的路线，每一步都小心翼翼沿着，再见！再见！路！路！路！非常棒。
Come on, that's pretty great. Smart. Last. Smart. Last. Last. Smart. Last.
得了吧，这相当棒。聪明。名单。聪明。名单。名单。聪明。名单。
SmartList is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjurf. Smart. Last. Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery App. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《聪明名单》由本尼·巴巴科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·阿尔姆朱夫纯天然手工作坊式制作。聪明。名单。我们的下一集将在四周内发布，无论你在哪里听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过在苹果播客或汪德瑞应用上订阅汪德瑞Plus来提前收听且无广告。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来发表评论。